Hey chip you out.
Why my brother?
Good to see you as always.
I always get a seat.
Thanks for jumping in this short notice for the folks who don't know.
I was supposed to have Kevin Leon today,
but Kevin and I,
we fucked up.
It was partially my fuck up.
Partially his fuck up but he'll be on on Wednesday.
Yeah.
Aig Bra was in the neighborhood getting pumped.
My friend getting getting solid.
You've been lifting the weights.
How steady are you lifting now?
I tried to get three days a week but shit gets crazy sometimes and I could only
get to two to five stop for just a couple of weeks.
I start at 51 just start getting so weak.
Even on TRT,
everything just start slipping.
He bought,
he's like,
Nah,
we don't need to be delivered to the shore is fuck.
I've been rolling with little people the last few months.
Like what kind of little people?
Hobbits?
I wish shit shit them up.
Do you think so?
I think Harvard's would be extraordinarily strong.
Hairy feet.
They're probably on a lot of like some kind of,
Nah,
man,
I bet their feet are fucking so strong.
Can never footlocker [inaudible] you seen the size of their heels?
They have giant hills,
but I bet their ligaments and shit are different.
I bet
there are bear.
This is weird about the hobbits right there.
Barefoot.
They got furry ass feet.
They have giant feet because you know obviously they had to wear those,
those feet over the shoes,
but even in the books didn't it didn't it did.
They said they had big herrings.
Look at those two books.
Yeah,
I Tom,
Holy Shit.
Out of that easy toehold hold right.
There may be.
Maybe my thinking is if their feet are that herring they got,
oh Jesus Christ.
What happened to that lady?
Don't do this to me,
Jamie.
This is the podcast that a person that's a through someone's got gout.
Inflammation.
No Man,
that's real.
Did you think that was a hobbit picture?
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Oh my God.
Google image.
Got You.
Again,
isn't that elephants algorithm?
That's the Russian,
so trying to fuck with this show.
No,
that is Bunyan's.
First of all,
that's a painful thing that happens to your big toe.
Some of it's genetic and some of it is putting your toes into pointed shoes for
like long periods of time.
Like people will have to go to work.
Like ladies particular,
they were like super uncomfortable shoes at smushed her toes up like that.
Your toes aren't supposed to be like that.
I've seen this thing on Instagram where they could fix that now with like rubber
bands.
Yes.
Well I think that's real.
Well the,
they have yoga toes.
There's some shit that you use that you can,
you shove your feet in between these like styrofoam things that stretches them
out.
Apparently that's supposed to be good for them.
Um,
Vibram shoes is good.
Let's still make those,
I run in those they can suit or something.
They did get to propaganda.
A bunch of pussies.
Really?
Yeah.
A bunch of behind her man.
I used to,
I used to learn too.
Yeah.
Look man,
they're,
they're harder to run in.
No Bull Shit.
Good though.
I like them.
But once you grip the ground,
all that shit came out that they were like a fraud.
They were sensing not what it is.
I think they had made improper claims.
If I'm not correct,
I mean if I'm not correct,
if I'm correct,
if my information is correct,
I think they made him proper claims.
I think that was what the word was.
The word was that they had said some shit and that people had gotten injured.
Like they said it would keep you from getting injured.
It's all based on the side.
Dia that you're supposed to run barefoot.
Yeah,
they said Mexican drinks and barefoot.
Yeah.
Mexico is like,
fuck you,
we got shows.
But those guys up in the mountains that they're talking about in that book born
to run,
I feel like they have,
some of them made their own shoes with like tires,
like that cut tires and made their own shoes and they're running like a hundred
miles up there.
Something crazy like that.
Like they have insane endurance and they live up in that mountain and they just
run around.
Oh.
Speaking of Mexicans.
One of the main reasons you're here.
I want to talk to you.
It's because you're my favorite Mexican and now we have a Mexican American
heavyweight champion of the motherfucking world.
That's crazy.
How crazy.
Sad.
That's insane.
I came to La,
Mexico.
Jesus Christ.
I didn't know Mexico had a heavyweight boxer.
Oh my God.
Andy Ruiz is the shit is the shit.
He's what America needs right now with all this border wall crisis shit and
heavyweight champion.
That's Mexicans come on son.
And one that's fucking good and one that has a big belly.
Any knocks out.
A dude who looks like he's chiseled out a granite.
I mean,
no one has ever had a better body than Anthony.
Joshua.
You've only had a different body.
No one's had a better bodies.
Like what is he like six,
seven or some shit and I,
Sam,
I don't mind know that.
God,
dude,
Anthony Joshua was the one of the best built heavyweight boxers of all time.
He's legit.
He was the champion.
All that Olympic gold medalist,
the champ knocked out Vladimir Klitschko.
I mean he's a fucking monster from the UK.
From the UK.
Yeah.
He was the champ and he was supposed to fight big baby Miller and big baby
Miller tested positive for the Mexican supplements.
Ironically enough.
Boom.
That's Anthony Joshua.
I mean,
come on son.
How tall is he?
Cause he's gigantic.
I've had a 12 pack because Andy Ruiz looked short in that fight.
Six.
Six Shit.
Yeah,
but Ruiz is like six to,
he just looked tiny when he's standing next to Joshua.
Joshua was a giant of a man and just fucking jacked.
What does it say is wait listed as two 49 to 40 or nine.
I wonder if that was for the last fight.
Cause I'm sure with a giant dude like that,
it varies back and forth.
But um,
so I was out to dinner and I get a text from Brendan Schaub.
Brenton shop hit me with a spoiler alert.
He said,
fuck,
Joshua got knocked out.
And I was like,
no.
And I go,
what happened?
And he goes,
he got fucked up in the seventh round.
I am Mexican.
And he goes,
I'm sick.
I go,
you're sick.
I go home.
Happy as fuck.
I'd locked.
I couldn't wait to come home and watch it.
I love when crazy shit happens.
This is my favorite thing in fights.
Look at that guy.
Look,
you re no disrespect champ,
but he jokes about it himself.
I'm trying to get him in here too.
Oh,
that would be cricket.
His body.
I mean it looks like a regular dude.
What have we got shredded?
How much would he weigh?
Why would you like it?
Get shredded?
No,
but if he did fuck out of here,
it might be a middle way.
I would feed him on the sneak tip.
I'd wake them up in the middle of the night with some great Mexican food.
That dude needs to stay exactly how he is.
See,
look,
he's got muscles under there like look at his stomach.
He's just got some body fat on them.
But here's one thing.
If you do have great cardio,
one thing that body fat can do is it can protect you somewhat.
It's like wearing eight sweaters.
I've joked around about this before and people think I'm bullshitting and I kind
of am a little bit,
cause I know most of the impact gets in there.
But if you were going to fight a guy and right before you fought him,
he puts on a vest made out of fat and meat and stitches it up and it sticks out
like fucking 10 extra inches.
He'd be like,
Hey,
what is all this?
What are you doing?
You can't put that on.
And then if you hit him to the body and he barely relaxed,
you'd be like,
fuck,
I can't believe this guy's cheating with his fat vest.
Hmm.
Think about that shit.
Yeah,
good cardio.
And you got some fat around your gut.
That shit might protect you.
Look at Daniel Cormier.
Yup.
Fade or look at Fay door.
You're dealing with these giant dudes,
giant dudes who can fuck you up with one shot.
There might actually be an advantage to having a gut.
And that's not bullshit at all.
It's not ideal in the lower weight classes.
Back guts he brought back on your backs.
Guts.
I'm thinking to grow in my own.
How great.
Healthy barely hanging on tired legs.
Chicks only dated dudes with guts.
That could be the new thing.
Yeah.
Dude.
Are you kidding?
Did you see that?
Uh,
that Gif on a Britain shops page of a Dj Khaled?
Is that how you say his name?
Who's a big fella himself climate out of a golf cart with a shirt open.
Look,
let me show you this.
I want,
I don't want to read the caption.
See my problem with sharing this is I want to know who the fuck made this cause
it's really funny.
I wish I knew the dude to give him credit.
You know.
Oh,
it says it there.
The creator of the gift.
Can I say it?
Yeah.
Put it up on there for him.
James.
Hold on.
Jamie's Tim was ghetto might be a problem.
Copyright issue.
Somebody might have stole it from somebody else.
You got to talk in the microphone.
People are listening to somebody else.
I'll just put it up.
Okay.
Look at this.
All the big meant all the big man headed to Brunch with their shirt open today
after the Andrew.
He's when
he's bringing back guts.
Dude,
that would be a man,
dude.
He's super friendly.
We like really nice guy.
Thank his mom.
So he told his mom after the fight,
you know,
we don't have to suffer anymore.
This has changed our lives,
you know,
it's beautiful.
It's pretty tight.
The last,
I mean,
I was,
I was crazy and do boxing before I saw UFC too.
Once I saw UFC too,
I kind of just drop boxing,
but I was way into boxing.
Had Stacks of ring magazine all over my house and wouldn't
throw them away.
I was way into it.
And all we had as Mexicans in the heavyweight division was Alex Garcia.
I remember him.
Yeah,
he was.
He broke the top 10 yeah,
he was up there for a little bit,
but he just,
you know,
that's,
that's the closest we ever got.
Unless there's been someone else since then.
This was like 1990 I haven't followed boxing at all.
Well,
that's why I was big for a Mexican Americans when Cain Velasquez was the UFC
heavyweight champ.
That was the first ever Mexican heavyweight champ in combat sports.
Yeah,
right.
Am I correct?
Yeah.
It's weird though,
in MMA,
uh,
people aren't racists in MMA really,
as much as boxing really raised like boxing.
I'm always going for the Mexican.
I don't want to fuck,
I don't give a fuck,
you know?
Yeah.
We talked about this,
but in [inaudible] Jitsu Guy,
I go,
I don't care what nationality you are in MMA or I go for the,
I want,
well,
like,
like if someone's fighting Melvin Manhoef,
I don't necessarily want Melvin Manhoef to win,
but I definitely want to see Melvin Manhoef go Melvin Manhoef on somebody.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah,
yeah,
for sure.
Oh yeah.
You know,
watching,
watching guys that,
that are known for their knockout power.
And I like watching those guys too,
even if they're fighting a Jujitsu guy.
Right.
I don't want them to win.
And that was why,
who was it?
Was it a Akiyama?
No,
it wasn't,
was it Akiyama?
No,
it was,
um,
who was,
uh,
was it Yoshida who beat Melvin Manhoef and arm Barnum?
I think it was your shoes and Akiyama.
I think it was Akiyama.
I think Akiyama I think sexy.
I'm fought him with a Gian.
Hmm.
I don't remember who fought Melvin Manhoef in pride.
See if it was a Melvin man who versus Akiyama.
I'm wondering,
Kay.
I,
yeah.
Sexy Yama.
You could say sexy Yama.
Who killed him?
Sexy on me.
It was it she Avello Michael Chavela did he,
I don't know who named him sexy Amaa Oh,
no,
he wasn't doing,
he wasn't doing pride right.
He was in Japan,
but I don't know if it was draining or no,
no,
no.
Yeah.
Well he does one now or he was doing,
he was doing all the shit on an access TV.
You know,
he was doing a lot of shows at pat military.
He's doing a lot of different things,
but he also does,
a lot of them are tied to Yoshi here.
I cannot be there.
Right.
Akiyama you gotta want to submit?
She rose hero got about that one.
Oh Wow.
That was the k one promotion,
right?
I think so.
Yeah.
Wow.
It's crazy how much this sport has changed and just in the time you and I have
been watching it to know from when you and I met in the 90s when we were doing
Jujitsu and you wear a purple belt.
Yeah,
I didn't Miss Shit back then.
I was on top of every Goddamn MMA fight.
Now I'm just like,
I'm lost.
There's so many promotional stuff now.
It's impossible.
So many UFC [inaudible] and it's,
it's hard to keep track and then I don't have time to keep track.
Everything's streaming.
I love like what is it on?
He has Penn APP,
like how do I watch this?
Once you get it on though,
once you figure it out and once you get it,
it works.
And once you get in and it works,
it's everything is on shit.
ESPN APP.
Yeah.
So you can get every phone and I sound like a shill for the company.
Now I'm going to say,
well look for it,
but,
and then I'm not.
But I'm saying like for me,
like when I watch fights,
it's pretty fucking easy once you get it hooked up.
The problem is people that don't have their TV hooked up to the Internet,
which is quite a few fucking people.
Then you got to watch it on a laptop.
That's not ideal.
Oh,
your phone.
That's not my ideal.
I'll do it though.
But that's the good thing about it is I've done that.
Like I've been out and I couldn't go to see a fight.
I couldn't watch a walls at home,
but I have like an hour.
That's where I could sneak away and watch like the one main event and I'll get
to watch it on my phone.
I'll take that all day.
Yeah.
What about like,
what's that function?
That mirror,
is that what it is?
Oh yeah.
We can shoot it up to the TV from your phone.
That's dope.
You could do that.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
If you have,
um,
apple TV,
if you have apple TV or if you have Amazon,
what does that fire stick?
Is that what it is?
Jamie?
Do you remember?
Yeah,
Chromecast,
Chromecast and there's probably a few other ones.
You could probably do that with two but they have like a USB slot I think.
And you just stick this thing in the USB slot and it a lot.
Is that,
am I saying that depending on what in your bought your TV right.
Built into it now a lot of them chrome thing,
which is interesting,
right?
It's like what if a new company comes along and they want to get built into
that,
that system.
How do they,
you know,
cause when you get your TV,
does your TV have like the option to get Netflix?
Mine does.
Yeah.
It's like you don't need an apple TV.
It's like one of the options.
Oh No,
no,
no.
On my TV I have a set up,
I have an old TV dude.
It's like I got it like in 2006 or something.
Damn son.
You gotta upgrade.
Yeah.
Just talking to upgrade is still a flat.
TV's don't know how like then you need it.
I'm going to go old school and I'm going to start riding a bike and getting
around the TV when I'm fucked up.
Davies with a dark in the corner,
the boxes,
big old box and you put stuff on it puts stuff on lance a shelf to the first
time I got a TV.
Um,
I got like,
it was a big ass TV.
Like my first TV that I bought when I first got on television,
it was like 30 inches or something like that.
It's like,
look at the size of this fucking TV.
It was giant like from here to here.
I was like that big and I remember sitting in the stupid hunting inch.
I remember sitting in the stupid thing on the floor and I had,
it had to be so far away from the wall because it was all this extra shit behind
it.
It was like tubes and stuff and bazookas there's like the,
you know,
it was wires and everything and this big box and fans and stuff.
You remember bulbs.
There was,
you'd be bulbs.
Him,
they'd have to change the bulbs and it make you TV brighter.
Do you remember that?
Uh,
yeah.
I don't really know the mechanics behind the TV that I just turn them on and
then when they break down and you Kinda,
they're so cheap nowadays.
Two TVS are crazy cheese.
Crazy.
We were just talking about that there.
How much like
a TV that for 10 years ago would cost and now it's like the same TV is like a
couple hundred bucks.
Yeah.
10 years ago it was like ten thousand fifteen thousand like I remember when I
first moved out I had a little,
you know,
everyone starts with their little black and white little boxes,
you know what I mean?
You put a clothes hanger in for the antenna and the first TV I was in 19 edge
color TV.
She has like 300 bucks.
I saved forever for it.
But man,
that was my pride and joy.
Yeah man.
No [inaudible] living in the days before TV when they first invented it was all
radio.
It was random play and movie theater existed first.
Right.
I'm not wrong in that.
Yeah.
How much after the movie theater did the television getting medicine?
Like what year was the TV?
I think the fifties that's when it came in.
The TD came in the 50s yeah,
probably.
That's not that long ago.
Think about how much dominates people's time.
Yeah.
The first TV started appearing in homes in the late twenties early thirties oh
shit.
Yeah.
I think color is when those like the 50s or so late twenties hold on.
How many TVS had homes in the 50s only 9% of American households had TVs in the
fifties one at a 10 rich folks.
Wow.
Managing,
just being alive back then when those things started happening and being some,
some do two things way,
way ahead and looks at us and goes,
Whoa,
where's this going to go?
People in 50 years are going to look back at this time and go,
Shit.
Remember when people used to actually open their eyes?
Now we're going to be like in some kind of Matrix for sure.
Memo and people lived real life to went outside the alive stupid fucking
dummies.
We're so lucky we could live anywhere.
You know when Vr gets so good that you actually can just live any life you want.
You know it's inevitable.
Yeah.
They're mean.
They're,
they're getting closer and closer to it.
If you look at what we uh,
would have seen if we were a person living in 1920 when they turned on that
first TV,
I mean,
what was that like?
Those people are probably like in awe.
They probably thought,
oh,
now,
now they can't lie to us on the radio.
Now we'll get the truth in our living rooms.
Now we got,
finally we got the truth.
We get to see what's really going on in the world.
At least borough and the 1920s know what they thought they were.
Just give me something to look at.
Yeah.
When you love to go back and talk to someone from the 20th that like,
what the fuck do you guys do?
Know how boring was like,
what are the Rod,
the hop hopscotch and shit like that and jump rope,
you know,
after a while that,
that just seems like so much fun.
Yeah.
Reading books and shit.
Remember that horses,
remember when people read books?
I rarely,
rarely I get almost 90% my reading I get done with audio books.
90%.
Yeah.
That's way easier.
It's great to do while running to,
they'd like,
it does two things at the same time.
It gives me some shit to think about.
That kind of like propels me while I'm running.
Don't do that.
Do I want to worry about getting jacked?
What do you mean?
Getting cat by a cat?
Oh,
do worry about that man.
Yeah,
I worry about that.
Legitimately.
I've been hiking,
uh,
more than ever lately and sometimes we're on some trails or have a rock ready to
go.
I carry a knife.
It's a good mood.
I carry a knife when I run.
It's a good move.
Yeah.
It's not likely.
People would go,
oh my God,
you're paranoid.
Two people were killed by mountain lions last year and a kid got bit by a
mountain lion just a couple of days ago.
Jamie,
I'm getting over a cold.
Folks from CFI sounds Snotty,
but,
uh,
if,
if two people got killed by Werewolf's,
would you go out when the moon fall?
You would like,
fuck that.
If two people in Seattle got killed by Werewolf's,
when there's a full moon,
you're going to lock your fucking doors.
Am I in Seattle when I go out of Seattle?
Where am I in Seattle?
Well,
the guy who's the Werewolf could've gone on a plane and went to San Francisco.
It's totally possible and right.
Or just walk to the few knew there was a real werewolf that was on the full moon
was possibly going to kill somebody.
Sometimes he didn't.
Sometimes the full moon comes and goes and nobody dies because everybody's smart
and they all stay indoors.
Yeah,
yeah,
for sure.
You would stay out of the,
you know,
the odds would be astronomical.
Just like,
uh,
like jaws,
like,
you know,
if you get dropped in the middle of the ocean,
you know that we have this guy,
it'll take,
this guy has a fucking mountain line and that's what is that?
That's not a mountain line.
That's like,
that's a domestic cat.
Is that a bobcat that looks like a map or a cougar.
Looks like a no,
that's a domestic cat.
See those ears?
It's like a really wild domestic cat.
What is it called?
See
Shit.
Is it his?
Is Adam?
The guy might be a dick.
The guy doing that fucking with that cap might be a dick.
He's trying to get it to hiss.
I guess they have a good relationship.
It looks like those.
What were those two?
They look like that like Holy Shit.
That is a for what kind of animals that links it to students doesn't the video
doesn't say what it is.
I saw him crazy.
I saw links in real life once.
It's crazy looking like a big,
these big giant fluffy feet.
I saw him up in a Alberta pig.
Weird,
crazy feat.
Like almost like they're wearing shoes.
Very strange looking cat like a big old furry cat in the woods and Canada.
It's so strange,
man.
You look at it,
you're like,
what the fuck are you?
You ever see a links?
I'm not too sure what the difference between the links and a cougar.
That's what I saw.
I saw him one of those motherfuckers.
I was like,
what is that fluffier bro?
They're super hairy because they're cats that live.
That's what it's like.
That won't the long legs right there,
Jamie.
That's like exactly what I saw.
And it was in the snow too or on.
It was not in the snow Rep.
It was a,
it was in the forest floor like green too.
When they,
um,
the feet are designed so that they can move quickly over snow.
They,
they almost act as snowshoes.
Like Soda Wolves,
like wolves have big ass feet and they spread out.
That's what it looked like.
We were driving down the road and we saw that guy on the side of the road and we
were like,
why is that?
What the fuck?
It's so weird to see one in real life.
If you see it at the zoo,
you wouldn't even look at it.
He'd pass by that cage.
He feel like,
what the fuck is fucking tiger?
That wack ass little cat and the crazy polar bears.
But if you see it in the woods,
man,
it's like the greatest thing you've ever seen in your life.
You're like,
wow,
look at it.
Look at it like a porcupine.
If I see a porcupine,
I'm driving,
I'll stop my car.
Like,
look at that.
Whoa.
What are they still,
do they really shoot?
No,
no,
they don't shoot.
They don't shoot him.
No,
no,
no.
Do Porcupines and lily don't shoot him.
Don't shoot him.
That's a myth.
They just have barbs.
So if you buy them,
you get stuck up.
How crazy is that?
Ever went thought that growing up like an eighties.
Cause kids lie.
They shot you with thorns.
Kids fucking lie to probably tell their dad.
He shot him at me.
Dad Ran a cartoon or something.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's possible too.
Right?
Like everybody thinks coyotes are a stupid,
yeah.
Like jaws,
you know.
Um,
jaws pretty much scared 95% of the population out of the ocean.
Oh yeah.
Out of the ocean.
Well,
the other guy just got jack.
You heard about that guy that just got jacked about,
right,
right.
Yeah.
You get,
well,
they don't know what kind of shark got on,
but got bitten Maui,
I think Mallory,
that's a lot of tiger sharks,
right?
Yeah.
Surfer surfer.
Um,
no,
I think it was a guy staying in a resort.
Just swimming died dead as far they find his body.
They got 'em.
I mean they brought him back to the beach,
but he had horrific wounds.
He died.
It just happened.
Yeah,
just happen.
man.
Sharks are no joke.
It's a terrifying animal.
And again,
if there was a fucking werewolf running around the woods exactly like a werewolf
just killed a guy last week.
Would you go to the woods?
Yeah,
it'd be just like jobs.
Like they had it on the news.
No,
no one would go.
But the thing is that sharks are sharks 24 hours a day,
seven days a week.
They don't only on full moons become shark.
But what about,
what about guys that say that that's totally blown out of proportion.
They swim with sharks.
They get in the,
in the ocean with sharks.
They're right.
I think the great wide is the only one that
the divers,
those crazy divers don't get in the water with.
Right.
But I think there was a lady that swam with a great white,
yeah,
there's pictures of Shit,
right?
We were,
we were um,
looking at her Instagram page once young Jamie,
do you remember that lady?
Yeah.
I'm just going to check.
Is it a trick?
Like she knows things.
She knows if it's pregnant you could go swim with it or something,
you know,
like,
uh,
those videos of,
of babies playing with King Cobras and then you find out that they defang them
so they can't hurt you at all.
They take their venom sac
too.
I think if that happens,
if they have a thing,
I might've made that up.
What's a venom sac?
Is that a real thing?
Is that I reckon nut sack,
but it sounds like I made it up.
Shark tank Brunswick,
the shark.
It's a eight foot nine inch white shark.
That's been just recently spotted yesterday or today I guess in oceans outside
of Ocean city,
Maryland.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
They,
this is the way its Twitter account works.
They like it speaks in the first person.
What if it kills some of the,
I'm sorry,
he was tasty.
I think it's still going to keep up the Twitter account.
If we know that shark killed somebody.
Look,
if it gets hungry enough,
all these assholes are overfishing in the oceans.
You overfished the fuck out of those oceans.
Eventually they'll sharks.
They're going to turn on each other.
You know?
That's what's happening with snakes in the everglades.
Do you know about that too?
Do you don't know about the everglades?
Nope.
Anacondas and pythons and shit.
Mostly pythons do tat them as pets in and they've got them cut them,
go and either finding them now there's 1718 feet long.
Anacondas are python python's shit.
They're eating alligators.
They did a study.
They did this fail then.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
They have photos of it and there's video.
There's video.
You can watch him eat an alligator in Florida,
in Florida.
God Damn,
they're giant and they're infested.
So they did like a biological survey of the everglades and they were down like
99% in some animals like deer,
99% marsh hair.
You're like,
Nah,
like 98% 95% raccoons.
That kind of shit.
They don't say anything.
Are they killing people too all day?
We,
I for sure some fucking rednecks have disappeared and they just don't talk.
Guarantee a guarantee.
A guarantee.
If you wanted to get rid of somebody,
man,
take him to python country.
Are they,
are they doing anything that your total population to these things,
how much you can do?
Have you ever seen the everglades to set up traps?
Dude,
you kidding?
Show Jay show any problems.
These are some geniuses with that kind of shit.
There's too many of them.
50,000 of what?
Snakes?
Yeah,
there's over a hundred thousand pythons.
Yeah.
How did they count?
They have rough estimates based on corn quadrants,
so like what they'll do is they'll take like,
it's not,
it's not a hundred percent accurate unless they tag all of them in which the
case they're assholes and she was just killed them.
But because they're an invasive species for people don't know.
They're not from Florida at all.
So they're just devastating the ecosystem and they're turning on alligators.
They're eating alligators now cause they basically run out of everything else to
eat.
It's,
it's a crazy fucking animal.
So what they would do is they would take,
I would guess like a chunk of the everglades,
you know,
like a hundred square yards or something like that and they'd measure the amount
and then they would do another one.
They would,
they would do it like several places and then take an average and then calculate
all the square footage.
And that's why that'd be pro or con hundreds of people would have been killed
already know because I don't think that many people first of all go in there and
I don't think they want to eat people.
I think they probably don't know what the fuck a person is where they see a
rabbit or some other shit that probably looks like food.
People are wearing clothes.
I'm just,
I know they do jack people though overseas.
There's been a horrible videos of guys getting cut out of giant snakes.
You never seen that?
I've seen.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Some poor villager.
Woman missing until they find the snake and they go,
we found her like they know they feel this motherfucker bounty hunter kills
Gargantuan Burmese Python gets 375 bucks and and earns our undying gratitude
thing.
Dude.
17 and a half feet.
So these things are Florida.
What like like Jacksonville or everglades?
Wherever the everglades on Miami.
The everglades is a giant ass one golf side middle.
Like the both sides kind of depending.
It's like a big swamp plan.
Show Eddie an overhead view of the everglades cause the everglades are fucking
bananas.
One thing that they found that was interesting,
it's like all that.
Yeah,
that shit.
Yeah.
So that all that stuff is done.
Swamp.
That's just monster soup.
The tip of the Dick of Florida is monster soup.
That's what that is.
You've got some leaves,
you've got some Bazell
fucking snakes.
You got some grass,
you got some shit growing out of the ground.
And you've got fucking alligators and snakes in a aliens vs Predator battle to
the death.
Howard,
uh,
Joey described the everglades.
Listen,
cock sucker.
These fucking dirty white people with stinky feet.
All you want to fucking snake.
Oh,
what do you want all,
I'm a Wiccan.
Get the fuck out of here.
The Guy Kicks his fucking kid out of the house.
The kid can't feed the snake.
Next thing you know,
monster soup shit.
I mean,
it really is down to these two super predators battling it out to the death.
And right now,
I mean,
I don't see any pictures of the alligators eating the pythons.
Do we have video of alligators eating pythons?
They're eating each other.
Okay.
So I guess it's just everybody's eating everybody.
Jesus.
Corralling that things got a whole deer in its body.
Is this Florida?
Yeah,
it's the same article.
Jesus Christ,
man,
they can swallow a whole deer that is so nuts.
They're not even as wide as us.
Imagine not being as wide as a person and you could swallow whole deer says it
fall.
It had a 35 pound white tailed Fonda in it.
It was eating 111% 11.1% I don't know.
111% it was a 31 pounds snake eating at 35 pound deer.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
They don't give a fuck.
They didn't read that part.
Oh my God.
That is so ridiculous.
Yeah,
they can eat their whole body weight,
but do you ever see that?
You've seen that we've showed that video of the frog or was a frog or a toad
that ate the mouse?
The mouse is bigger than him,
Bro.
He's just fucking eats it.
He just,
I didn't know that toads did that.
I had no idea.
This video,
there's like the little wow white mouse is in this cage.
Just like looking around with his frog and this frog just like slowly comes
close to him.
Slowly come closer and then swap.
It says half his body and you see this mouse trying to kick and get the fuck out
of there.
The fog just like slowly just choke some dial
insects.
That's what I thought too.
If they figured it out.
See if people believe in evolution,
right?
I believe in evolution.
If people believe in evolution,
why do we think it stops with us?
Why don't we think these guy frog's going to take over maybe like one of the
first,
the first signs of it was this pepe,
the frog controversy on the Internet.
Maybe it's shots fired,
things to come.
These frogs are going to start eating meat and the Trump fraud.
Maybe these frogs are eating meat.
That's what's going on.
Can get smarter.
Pepe Pepe,
the frog was,
was that around before Jamie?
What is this Jamie?
Oh,
I've seen that.
Has a thing this next fuck.
Yeah,
tacking a cat.
Whoa.
The cat comes over to swat the fucking snake.
Cats are ruthless,
bro.
Are Ruthless
as just a compilation of frog.
Eat and shit.
Well,
there's one that's like super specific that I found on yo use his hands.
That might be his hand.
The stuff that we're looking at.
This one,
here's one.
It's,
Oh,
they're only showing part of it.
It's just,
it's a bunch of shit.
Like look how he gets that whole mouse in his mouth.
Damn.
This isn't even the same one.
So there must be multiple videos of,
I guess that's a toad.
Is that a frog or a toad?
I honestly do not have the difference in that one.
But I think frogs are like green
frogs live in water.
Right.
And toads hang out on the grass.
I think they,
hmm.
When I was in Costa Rica,
the first night I was,
I was in,
I went with a bunch of friends and they had this mansion dude right there in the
Jones.
Oh,
we talked about the,
I remember,
yeah.
And,
and the first night I doused my whole,
but I knew the bugs we're going to come out.
So that was when we got there.
I'm like,
Oh my God,
I'm going to get attacked by bugs.
So I die.
I went to the neighborhood store and but all their off and just use it like
Moose all over my body.
And we sat,
we were sitting there as the sun set.
We were at the pole and it was like 10 of us at the pool.
And as the sun was setting,
all these frogs just appeared out of nowhere.
It was scary.
And the guy that lived there is that,
trust me,
don't be scared.
They're going to be your friends.
Like,
what do you mean goes?
Trust me.
We're going to need them and go for the bugs.
He goes,
yes.
So when the sun went down,
we're,
we're at a pool and this JZ tight mansion at a pool in the middle of the jungle
and there's all these frogs everywhere.
And then the bug started coming.
You never saw the same bug twice.
And it was like Braveheart dude.
They were,
all these frogs are just,
you just see them attacking these bugs.
It was,
it was,
uh,
like a war.
He
was crazy in the hogs.
Lost the bugs.
Lost frogs.
Jack liked like those white walkers do.
They fucked him up,
dude.
Wow.
That's an amazing,
very entertaining.
It was very entertaining.
We're just sitting there going,
Holy Shit.
Get those bugs.
Fuck those bugs up.
Why doesn't someone make a documentary about that?
It's crazy.
The war,
the daily war in the jungle.
When the bugs come out,
fucking frogs eat bugs and frogs.
What a what a weird place to choose to put a mansion when I get you want to be
able to scream?
No.
One thing I learned,
one of the thing I learned about that trip is there's the people that liked that
shit or the,
the people that will like,
they'll see a trench that and pick it up and go and try to scare you with it and
then the fucking eat it or whatever.
Like you have to be one of those people like,
you know,
people like me who are scared of bugs.
Uh,
I,
I'm not a jungle guy.
I'm a snow guy.
I want to,
I just went to Lake Tahoe,
we went to squaw valley.
That's my shit.
Snow too cold for any bugs.
The jungle.
If I never go to another jungle ever,
I wouldn't give a shit at a horrible time.
That the last time I was in a giant cow and had a similar story about when he
was trying to be a bugged scientist.
What's that called?
Fuck it.
Just trying to be an entomologist and he was hanging out in the,
in the jungle with these people and they had to put Turpentine on the posts of
the,
like the platform with a tent sat for the ants.
Yeah.
Cause the answer would be marching through the juggling.
Said you to hear them walking.
You could hear them.
Yeah.
You can hear the ants.
There's so many of you could hear him shut the fucking jungle dude.
Fucking jungle.
That's why if you had to choose between cold or or unbearable heat,
I'd always choose comb.
Yeah.
The thing about cold is it's like you can get warm,
you know when you're hot you can't really get cool.
It's hard.
You can get cool in your house,
but you could start a fire in your house and you just wear warm clothes outside
and you just live smart.
Yeah.
It's about the challenges of,
that's interesting when you look at like population in the world,
because in this country,
not the world,
but in this country,
all the places where it gets really cold population gets limited.
Like it's only gonna get so big.
But when things like sweet,
real nice,
like especially like La,
like Ooh,
people just pile in.
But I guess New York's the argument against that because New York's Phoenix
though it's opposite.
It's like super hot there.
Melts everybody.
Yeah,
but people like to party down there.
If you'd like to party,
if you'd like to party,
you go to Phoenix.
Hillman is where I live.
I live in Phoenix,
open carry state.
The fucking sheriff Arpaio makes everybody wear pink underwear and pink
jumpsuits and shit's crazy stake.
If you look at where people live,
I think generally speaking,
white people like cold and darker people like the heat.
It seems that way because if you look at the North Pole with genetically,
if you look at the North Pole,
looking down on it,
all the surrounding countries,
they're all white.
Right?
But you know why,
right?
Because they want to be next to the,
they want to be close to the North Pole.
Is that,
why did the one we say on this first stop?
A,
there's,
there's uh,
it's supposedly a magical place.
The North Pole.
Well,
it's because they don't get any vitamin D up there because it's hot as fuck
where they're from.
And sunny weather from originally.
And then as people migrated and got these northern climates,
their skin became paler and Paler like a,
like a solar panel for vitamin D.
That's where you get it.
You get it from the sun.
So because they don't get much vitamin D because there's no fucking sun out,
it's cold as shit.
It's cloudy and England and Ireland and all these bills are and go really,
really white.
It's fucking cloudy all the time,
man.
It's cold as fuck.
So you're not getting that vitamin D plus your whole body's covered and fucking
minks and animal skins and shit.
That's why they're all white.
They're all from the same thing.
That's what's weird about it.
But there's also some,
some growing evidence that there was a whole gang of different kinds of people
that are finding these new Russian people called Dennis Oh ovens.
They found bones of them.
So they think there was like maybe a bunch of other versions of human beings
that we just lost in time.
And then you're going to probably find that as people get further and further
into DNA testing to find more and more different versions of people and people.
There's supposedly a lost empire in Russia called Tardy.
We ever heard about that?
No.
Yeah.
It's supposedly erased from all history for different reasons.
Um,
I don't really know that much about it,
but it keeps popping up on Youtube.
I thought it was a juvenile.
I would make a joke about the,
the name of it.
Tardy.
Yeah.
I would make a joke.
What would you say?
Let's say something terrible.
Like what?
Tardy.
Yeah.
I can't think of anything.
I wonder why they didn't make it.
Okay.
That guy,
Graham Hancock,
who wrote that book,
did you ever listen to a podcast?
I did with him recently.
Not the recent one,
dude.
He was talking about the Amazon and that hidden civilizations that were at one
point in time in the Amazon.
Then European settlers or European explorers rather came there and gave them
smallpox and it burned through the entire fucking population just like it burned
through the native Americans,
same deal and just wiped out these huge cities.
People just abandon these huge cities.
And he was saying that at one point in time they think as much as 20 million
people are living in the Amazon and they had these really big established
cities.
So now they're using this stuff called Lidar.
It's like light like laser that they shoot from a fucking plane and they make
maps of the giant cities and find berries sees dude.
It's crazy.
It's amazing to watch because the first European explorers,
when they went to the Amazon,
according to grant Hancock and his book,
which is called America before,
um,
the first European explorers,
when they came to the Amazon,
they were like,
oh my God,
this is incredible.
These,
they have these massive cities and sophisticated culture,
and they wrote back about it.
Then when people came back hundreds of years later,
everything was gone.
It was all just engulfed by the jungle because all the people died off after the
fucking European explorers came.
So the European explorers came.
They spread their diseases.
They came in,
I don't know how many boats over how much time they wrote things about it and
then everybody fucking died.
They died like a,
just a like a haunted curse.
Like they brought a curse to a place and then the jungle overcame the city and
grew through the pillars of the floor and just took over and now they're finding
it through all this new sophisticated technology where they get scanned through
the trees and just get images of what the ground looks like and then they take
this image of the ground and you could see these grids see buildings.
It's amazing the irrigation that they could survive in the jungle with all of
that fungus and bacteria and viruses,
bugs and all that shit.
But smallpox takes them out.
Small crops jacked him.
They weren't ready for it.
They didn't have,
it was probably not a small pot.
It's probably a gang of diseases that the,
I mean smallpox for sure killed a lot of people during that time period,
so they assume it was smallpox and smallpox most likely was one of the diseases,
but I bet they gave him a bunch of other diseases too.
These fucking people had no immune system for any of the shit that Europeans
were running over there.
And I bet the same thing would happen if someone from there went to Europe.
I bet they have some weird parasites and weird shit that if they could somehow,
I mean I guess you could imagine like people that live in the jungle and must be
exposed to certain parasites or certain certain diseases are germs that they
don't get in Europe either for transferring them back and forth like that would
probably wouldn't know.
Like if they went and visited like a giant ship full of Amazonians went to visit
Europe,
they probably would have given him some strange disease.
Like,
dude,
can you imagine and wonder if those guys brought anything back?
I wonder if they got anything from the Amazon people and brought it back.
Vaginal parasites.
Derek and I believe you went there,
man.
Imagine the kind of sexual diseases they add in the Amazon,
but they were immune to that.
Europeans were like just dying on the phone management.
Everybody's [inaudible] and a coral grown on their dicks.
There's no deodorant.
They probably didn't use soap and you've probably got used to it.
You know,
they say people are used to smells.
You get,
that's why people that live in those towns where they have a factory and
everything smells like chicken shit or something like that.
Those people get used to it.
When you drive,
when you're on the four oh five and you pass by that Budweiser plant,
it smells like it has that weird like almost fried fried food or something.
Or you're like,
what is that?
And you drive into San Pedro and it smells like the sewer.
You know when you're on the seven 10 or the one 10 is there's certain places,
there's certain places where you you like in New Jersey,
when I was a kid,
I remember there was areas that grow by that had factories and you could see the
fucking smoke coming out of the factory.
They were just spewing it.
It would stink.
The whole fucking city would stink.
And if you lived though,
you just had to accept that,
you know,
if you live there,
there's no fixing that.
That's just what the town smelled like.
That was your reality.
That's crazy.
What do you think of um,
five g and all that scared.
You think that's the terrified of they're all that shit scared?
Yeah,
because how much long term testing have they done?
Net zero or negative numbers.
They're putting them up,
dude.
Is that what,
uh,
when,
when I'm driving around with my family,
my wife is obsessed with recognizing plates.
She's always calling out Florida,
Oregon.
She's her and my son.
They got a little game they play.
They're always looking at the plates.
I am always looking at cell phone towers and satellite dishes.
I'm always,
yeah,
all satellite dishes point to the southeast for some reason or other.
And that's what I always check them off.
They don't point to the north in southern California that just direct TV.
So that's all words.
All satellites,
every side dishes.
It's pointing to the consumer consumer satellite.
Every satellite dish that I've seen,
I,
I'm obsessed with them.
They're always point.
They never point to the north.
They're always pointing south east.
All of them.
The great majority of satellite dishes that you see are probably like direct TV
or I've noticed all of them.
All of them.
But you go,
uh,
it's,
it's crazy.
I don't know why.
I don't know why,
but also those a cell phone towers.
I was on this website called um,
uh,
smart meters.
murder.com smart meters,
murder.com I was trying to remember it.
Smart meters,
murder.com dude,
you want to get your fucking head blown off.
Go to that website and read the documents that they're pulling from different
agencies.
Dude,
scary.
What are you talking about?
Scary.
But we just kicked it in stone.
You know what,
you're going to have to go check that shit out but it's like on five g but back
from back from their documents from government agencies,
from 2001 July,
2001 it was like this whole,
I don't know how big like 400 page plan for the world.
It's a plan for the world they're talking about who wrote this plan.
The way you're holding that here while you do it,
it is quite hilarious.
It's the perfect like if someone was talking about a conspiracy theory and they
had a blunt and they would just like full bore conspiracy job while they're
holding the joint.
It's so scary dude that I don't even want to talk about it.
Let's change the subject.
You know if you want to look into it,
go to smart meters.co a smart meters murder.com but it's scary.
Do you have ready want to talk about it?
I have read things where people are questioning the the like whether or not five
g is going to be healthy,
but I haven't seen anything that verifies it is or it isn't.
I haven't seen anything that says I need to look into it,
but,
but just in what I'm worried all told is that I really think that Wifi signals
all the various signals that surround us all the time.
I think they have an effect on us and I don't know what that effect is.
I don't know if it's negative or positive.
I don't know if it didn't it,
it dulls the senses.
It's entirely possible that it does something to dull the sentence because it
occupies an area.
I mean if we have the capability of recognizing the fact that they're the
theaters,
you signals around us all the time.
Cellular signals,
signals,
radio signals,
satellite signals.
We're surrounded,
constantly buy signals.
Are we absolutely sure that our body doesn't have the capacity to recognize
those signals even though we don't have like a really clear method of taking
those signals in and then translating them into visuals or into audio.
But because we can't take that Sirius satellite signal and then t and then have
like a player in our head because of that,
we assume that we're not taking it in in some way.
That's what these,
that's what this uh,
report,
Oh,
let me just give me,
is about,
it's about bay.
This is why I say,
this is why I say this,
because when I feel the least foggy is when I'm in the woods.
When I'm in the mountains,
when there's no cell phone service,
there's no radio service.
There's no Wifi,
there ain't shit.
It's warehouse.
How satellites don't work when someone's in the woods.
But no satellites do work.
You could actually not show,
not knowing the wash.
You get a dish you put on the roof of your car,
you can watch TV.
That's a new thing that Steven Rinella.
Dot.
Leon's work on satellites.
No phones work on cell towers,
but the GPS works on satellites.
Okay,
so your phone still works as a gps unit when you're in the woods,
even if you don't have any signal show,
she could find your way out with a map if your phone was on,
you know there's people that say that GSP,
the GPS,
GSP,
the GPS is also run by the towers to that don't need to go into space that you
could triangulate your position from towers and loan,
but that's,
you probably could try triangulate your position from towers,
but you couldn't broadcast as such a gigantic area like you can with satellites.
You can see satellites,
the people that think that satellites aren't real,
they need to talk to somebody who makes satellites,
they,
they're there.
You can see them with telescopes there up there.
We have the ability to tune in to the very specific spot in the sky with the
direct TV and you'll pick up the signal.
That's how you get the signal.
You tune to the spot in the sky with the satellite is,
and you'd pick up the signal.
They're real.
People have a problem with fucking everything that's ever existed.
Everything.
Everything's fake,
everything's fake.
Maybe we'll think of it is how many people think that we're living in a
simulation.
Really,
really fucking smart people thinking that's okay.
That's okay.
That isn't crazy,
dude.
That's the craziest thing about all conspiracy theories,
like people that um,
uh,
are not on that side.
There's a conspiracy theory to side and then there's the people way on the other
side.
Those motherfuckers are totally into,
man,
we live in a computer.
That is hilarious.
That's not logical.
It's illogical.
Well,
the,
the reason why they think does cause some day there's going to be a program,
but it's going to be a to be true.
It may be true.
Maybe we do live in a computer,
but dude,
there's no evidence.
No,
there's no
evidence on these conspiracy theories of if you look into each one individually
tab,
maybe it's true.
Maybe it's not,
but there's actual evidence is enough evidence to prove it one way or another.
Who knows?
But don't talk shit on.
It's not the same like government conspiracy.
It's dude,
I've never heard,
I've never heard anybody like that's easy to categorize people like that.
No sane people to believe that I know that you know about people.
What I'm saying?
No,
no.
Okay.
For sure.
I haven't done any surveys,
surveys.
This is all based on the people that I come in contact with.
Did I?
I,
I would say people,
you know,
80% of my students that are not a conspiracy theorist,
I don't even think about it.
They're just like regular people.
They don't,
they don't,
uh,
they don't concern themselves with it.
Right.
You know what I mean?
They think it's amusing that I'm into it,
but they're not into it.
You know what I mean?
But those same people,
when you say duty,
you know,
Elon Musk says that we might live in a computer and everyone's like,
it may be true,
but dude,
there's zero evidence of that,
that we live in a fucking computer.
What was the evidence?
Where's the evidence?
What did someone,
someone propose some sort of theory that proves that life is a hologram.
One wasn't a Hologram.
That life is a simulation.
Someone proves somehow I'd like to see that.
I tried reading this book,
the Holographic Universe,
but I didn't get into it.
Maybe I should revisit it saying it's not true.
I'm just saying there's just that,
oh,
I know.
It might not be the same fucking people that you're talking about that do or
don't believe,
but people definitely get rigid.
That's called to believe that you could talk to her.
Like,
you know,
Elon Musk said it.
It's called,
it's like a cool thing.
You know?
You could be way on the left.
You could be way and just like,
oh yeah,
we might live in a computer.
Man.
It's interesting that,
that's fascinating to me.
I think the reason why they say that is because one day we will,
and we all know it.
We all know it.
We all know that one day you could be in something that's as ridiculous is what
you're experiencing right now.
And it could be a simulation.
Yes,
yes.
But they believe that's what happened.
Yeah.
Well,
renting on pay might not necessarily believe it,
but they're entertaining.
The idea of the theory is,
yeah,
we might,
we might be in a computer simulation.
You know what?
I mean,
he might be living in a computer simulation.
Yeah,
maybe.
Maybe.
I'm not saying we don't,
I'm just saying,
dude,
there's no evidence of that.
Right,
but the keywords might,
so to just explore an idea like are we living in a simulation?
It doesn't mean you probably see nothing wrong with that.
Yeah,
that's what I'm talking about.
That's like a conspiracy.
That should be one of the,
you should lump.
It's logical to lump that in with all those like nine 11 conspiracy,
like nine 11 for instance.
There's lots of evidence that it was an inside job,
but that's a crazy conspiracy to most people.
But then if you look into it,
they're scientific.
They're science supports that it was an inside job.
Then science,
despite Sta,
no button,
there's still science to dispute it.
No,
no,
for sure.
But there's evidence,
right?
I'm not saying,
but what other it's true or not.
I'm just saying I don't want to go into a nine one one inside job conversation.
I'm just saying I'm just my,
I'm going to be using that.
I'm just using that as example,
like as a,
that's a crazy conspiracy theory,
but there's a lot of evidence whether it's true or not,
who knows?
You know what I mean?
Um,
I think it was an inside job,
but a lot of people don't and whatever,
but there's zero evidence of us living in a computer simulation.
We're not talking about the same people.
They might not be the same people that believe one or the other.
They're different lumping them together.
No,
no,
I'm not.
I'm,
there are different.
There are different people.
I mean,
I,
I know,
but the people that don't want to believe that and don't want to look at the
evidence I'm saying aren't necessarily the same exact people as the people that
believe winners.
Their relation.
You're right.
I have,
there's no poll on it.
I haven't taken a poll.
I'm just going,
can I sing it to nine one one you just went,
you wanted to talk about it,
so you've got to send to it.
That's,
that's,
yeah.
We don't want to tell him about nine 11.
I was just using that as an example.
I know what you're saying.
You know people believe weird shit.
They definitely do like the people that really want to believe in bigfoot or the
people that really want to believe in Ufos.
UFOS are coming back right now.
Everybody's talking about it ever bigger than ever.
Stronger than ever.
That I should tell you something.
Dave Foley's hooked Dave Foley from news radio.
I remember Dave Foley hooked.
We text each other almost exclusively about UFO evidence.
Dude,
I know many days.
I was the biggest office in New York Times a couple of days ago.
Oh Wow.
What is that?
Navy pilots report identified flying objects.
Here's the thing though,
we don't know what kind of shit the Chinese have figured out.
We don't know what kind of shit the Russians figured out.
We assume that we know cause,
but we didn't.
We didn't let them know about the stealth bomber or any of the crazy shit that
they were building an area 51 we didn't let them know.
Do you know me?
I was balls deep into the,
you know,
community did my tattoo.
The first Tattoo I got it.
I got an alien on my left arm.
Any Julian garb.
I was always into fucking ancient Egypt,
the conspiracy side of the ancient Egypt.
There's the mainstream Egyptology I was into that though.
Oh look what Graham Hancock is saying.
And you F O's fun.
That's so fun.
There's so much proof in my head,
there was so much proof that the government was trying to cover up.
Look,
the,
why are they covering it up?
Why are they covering it up?
And look at all these guys from pilots,
from the air force are saying they saw ufs pilots from the navy or saying they
suck.
You will foes dudes from the Pentagon.
It's gotta be true.
That's a dude.
That's a CIA pilot.
He's saying it.
So when you're,
when you're balls deep and you really want to believe it,
you look at it that way,
you're like,
look,
there's all these government officials saying they saw you fos and they got
their own Ufo story.
You know.
And then,
um,
you know,
you listened to Bill Cooper and he was former office of naval intelligence
officer and you know,
and,
and when you hear what he says,
Shit,
he wrote that book,
behold a Pale white horse he gave me that guys had crazy shit.
He said there's a base on the moon.
Not that guy.
That's your talk.
Behold a pale white horse.
He said there's a based on the mass.
Yes.
No,
he at first didn't need at first.
Now you're talking about lear.
You're talking about
pop stars from that guy is crazy too,
right?
Totally.
What does that guy say?
He says that um,
there's millions of people on each planet in,
they're all,
every planet has millions of people.
Is he the guy that owned skin Walker ranch?
I don't know.
But he was a part of his dad owned Leer jet.
Right.
I forget what that does.
Seems like a super rich troll.
Totally.
When he says what he says to crazy shit,
he says,
I'm like,
this guy's having a good time fucking with people.
Yeah,
totally.
Totally.
But Bill Cooper says that,
um,
because his job was to prepare notes,
top secret notes,
classified shit it for meetings with high level people in the military and he
was based on what he was reading.
He was like,
damn,
Ufos are real.
Look,
I have proof.
So the,
at first he was like,
for sure Ufo is a real and for sure they're hiding him.
That's what he was saying.
He was preaching that.
Then he learned later they let him whistle blow.
He never got busted for whistle blowing that they w they want him,
they wanted him to lead that Ufo.
That's what his conclusion was.
He started to realize,
wait a minute,
they want me to leak this.
And then he,
he,
he got to the point where he believes that all Ufo abductions like,
oh,
like the,
he believed that um,
everything was a product of the government.
All UFO sightings,
abductions.
They're taking you in.
It's,
he believes it's like the CIA doing that shit.
And he was,
that's what he was really about before he got killed.
He got murdered man.
They went up to us ranch and fuck them up.
If they wanted to really fuck with you,
this is what I think they would do.
They,
first of all,
they put acid on your shit.
They put apps on your door knob or something like that.
Cause there was a dude who found something.
I forget what he found,
some old thing.
And as he was opening it up,
he,
I just,
by touching it,
it was like some old thing.
It was dipped in acid and he went on an acid trip for like six hours.
So this is what they'd do.
They'd dose you up,
they'd somehow or another dose you up whether touching a doorknob.
Finally Guy,
it's unreal.
Recent story.
A guy that was cleaning up a board like this,
a soundboard.
That's what it was.
He touched.
That's what it looks.
Just like,
Aww.
Tell him his girlfriend's gonna think I'm fucking high.
Yes.
Ended up testing.
That's exactly the story.
So they could do that to you and then sneak up on you with some special effects
where some fucking crazy mask and fucking flashy with lights and you're so crazy
high.
You don't know what the fuck's going on.
They grab you and put you on a table,
a desk,
and tell you,
you,
you've been abducted by aliens from another planet.
You don't think they fucked with people and did stuff like that do for a fatty
they.
Have you seen the documentary abducted and plain sight?
No,
I have not.
Which ones that do?
What's that about?
It's exact.
It's about Ufos.
Well,
it's sort of sort of this guy,
he was married,
had a couple kids.
He was
tight with the family who had three daughters.
He was a predator.
So he targeted,
he targeted the 12 year old.
And what he did is he,
uh,
had some fucked with the mom.
Fuck with the Dad,
fuck with the dad.
And next with the dad is sexual relations in some dad.
The Dad jerked him off.
Oh Jesus.
They talk about this in the past to just jerked him off.
The guy jerked him off.
He got,
he convinced the guy to jerk him off.
So we wanted black male on the parents so that once he took the daughter,
they couldn't say shit.
And the black man because he jerked him off and he fucked with the mother too.
And it was,
it was a secret.
So I wish that guy doesn't want none of that shit.
That's the guy.
Take his kid,
he's going to t he asked to take the daughter,
uh,
horseback riding.
So,
and they were like,
okay.
So he takes the daughter horseback riding and what he does is he starts telling
her that there's all these alien abductions going on and we got to be careful
for aliens.
She's 12 years old,
so he sat in her up.
So when he does,
he drugs her,
she wakes up,
she's strapped to a table,
he's got a speaker with alien voice is coming out and the alien and she wakes
up.
She didn't know where she's at.
She's like,
oh my God.
And this,
this alien voice says that she is a responsible for saving the earth.
She has to marry that dude.
She has to marry the dude in the alien voice.
You have to marry Bob and you have to have this,
but you can't tell nobody.
And the rugs,
I don't know.
And then she passes out again when she wakes up and she's not strapped.
She's looking around the trailer and she sees the guy,
he's about,
he's pretending,
he's all fucked up and she's like waking him up and he's like,
you know,
it's fake blood on him or whatever.
And then he wakes up and then she tells him,
we've been abducted by aliens and I need to have your child.
Oh my God.
He tricked her.
So from the age of 12 to 16,
he owned her good.
They ended up catching him with a girl.
Like a week later,
FBI gets involved and um,
the girl can't tell anybody or everyone dies,
so such.
And so she's obsessed.
Now she's back with their family.
The guy's in jail for like a day because you know what he does is he has his
lawyers send,
uh,
letters to the mother and father saying,
to make him a sign like that,
it was consensual.
What?
He threatened the black male.
So they signed it and let him out.
They signed in,
they let him out and then he goes to like the next state over.
But that chick,
she's like,
she's 12,
13,
14,
and she's obsessed with him.
She has to save the world.
So that,
that's an example of,
and then it turns out,
it turns out that I think the guy was CIA probably,
and he knew that he knew those techniques.
That's how they get people.
They fill them up.
There's all these alien abductions,
get them all scared and then boom,
when they do what they believe in Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
So that's just mk ultra did dude,
she got MKL truth.
I guarantee you they did that to people who are like political enemies.
Fuck.
Why wouldn't they do that?
It's easy.
It just seems like something they would do to just seems like it makes sense.
And then Bill Cooper,
um,
said that,
uh,
the mutilated,
terrible thing that people were saying,
Oh,
you let those who are taking them because you know,
they're,
uh,
the Oregons were taken out so surgically that we don't have the either.
But what Bill Cooper he was,
he got balls deep into that.
He started getting into breaking down.
What's really happening with is he's gone,
Oh shit,
we're being,
we're,
the government is pretending to cover it up there.
They want to push it.
They want people to believe in alien.
So what do you think that the counter mutilations where you think they were
testing weapons on these cattle?
Bill Cooper said it was really simple.
All the cattle are found by military basis.
And what they do is they,
when they're constantly checked,
checking radiation levels around basis constantly.
So what they do is if there's cows,
they'll go routinely take a cow,
take out it's rectum,
take out at like certain Oregon surgically and then they dumped them just to
scare people.
Just let them,
it'll kill two birds with one stone.
They really needed to get some radiation,
um,
a test.
But it's always good.
It's always good to push you.
Fos.
It's always good to scare people with aliens.
I wonder if those,
those uh,
cattle abductions,
if they coincided with areas where there was like some sort of toxic dump,
you know,
someday ammunition dump or something like that.
Like anything where some corner,
what do they have more of them around Nevada where they did all those nuclear,
I'm not sure,
but the gist of what Bill Cooper said was found near military bases and he knows
once he looked into it,
it's like,
oh,
I know what they're doing.
They're checking radiation levels and they're scaring people at the same time.
Hmm.
That makes sense.
Because it was surgically removed.
Right?
Like people can do that.
Like why would that eliminate the possibility that people could do it?
Of course people could do it,
but Pete,
you know,
people like to eat.
Only aliens could do that.
And then they take it and then they move it to another place so that the blood
is not in a spot where they find the animal.
That's all it is.
I'm a crazy,
that's how they catch poachers,
you know?
Do you know that?
Oh,
they catch poachers that way.
Sometimes they find out where the gut pile is.
So like say if you,
uh,
you didn't really have a tag to shoot a deer and then you shot a deer and
another place where you're not supposed to be,
but you have a tag at a different place.
You,
you just cause of,
there's some places where it's easier to get tags.
He just take the deer out of the forbidden place,
take a picture of it or something like that and then go back home.
Well they busted people because they like Park Rangers recognized certain
mountain peaks and the like,
no,
you weren't there.
I know exactly where you were when you,
when you killed this dear,
you were at a different place.
And then they go to that different place and they code,
they look at the,
fit,
the picture and they try to coordinate and then they find the gut pile and then
they convict people of poaching that's happened before they look at the photos.
Yeah.
So like so that's what Bill Cooper.
That makes sense that they would do that.
That they would do it because when you,
if you think you took that animal and killed and cut it and left this big bloody
patent,
then put it in a truck and then dragged it 10 miles away and dropped it off
there.
People be like,
this is crazy.
There's no blood at the scene of the crime.
All the bloods missing.
It's been removed.
Like no
one could do this.
This is impossible.
Literally no blood on the ground.
Yeah,
because they put it there.
You fuck you fuck wit.
You think aliens came this far to fuck with cows?
Imagine if we went all the way up to like Neptune shoot gophers,
which is going to get there.
Fuck up your gophers.
Neptune Jack them cut their decks off,
thrown back.
It's funny,
man.
That's exactly what they thought aliens did and it's hilarious.
Cattle mutilations are fucking hilarious in that regard.
Yeah.
It's gross too though that they did it so many times that it became a thing that
people looked for and then they let all these people who believe in aliens
anyway that let all these people just still are trying to scare us.
They're trying to scare us with aliens.
For sure.
Maybe that's what book foot's about.
Maybe big foot was about to let's,
let's create this mythical monster and have people afraid.
They don't want people to move in the woods.
The thing about it,
that's not good,
that's not good for the Nwa.
They want people to go into cities,
so they create these big floods.
If they not doing it,
they should do is create another Bigfoot's.
That's,
that's the most easy way reason for believing in bigfoot I've ever heard.
That's so funny.
Thanks for,
it's been around forever though,
Dude.
They talked about it in the CIA's been around forever and it was in the native
American culture before the Nazis did that.
Tabitha Nazis like have,
I bet if you go to Germany,
they have these mythical creatures that they created a scare people out of the
woods.
If they're not,
if they're not doing that damn,
they got to give me credit if they started doing it because that's how good
illuminati move right there.
Right.
That's how crazy deep you have to be.
If you're a conspiracy theorist,
if you go so deep,
you think that the CIA was in the native American's before Columbus landed.
You don't even understand.
It had a different name.
It was the Steelers need about air can organization.
They taught the European,
maybe the CIA of the Apache,
cause you know they had to have some evil elites that lied to their people.
Right?
Maybe they wanted to keep their tribes together.
So they said they created these monsters so you can't go out there and we're
going to protect you because you got to stay here.
Wouldn't that be a good move for,
it's probably exactly what happened.
Right.
And they got these crazy stories of these monsters.
Yeah,
man,
you got to stay here and protection.
CIA.
Yeah.
Native American sex.
Just Brown building empires.
One O one you create,
you scare them with aliens.
We got a threat from up here,
so we need to protect you.
And then we got threats down here.
Two jobs,
maybe jobs as a CIA moving.
Let's keep people out the ocean.
We got to keep them in the cities.
It's all CIA,
Bro.
Everything is all powerful.
Imagine if they just worked for good instead of trying to,
you know,
what they do at the native American community.
Mo Most,
I'm sure most of the people in the CIA,
I really legitimately trying to stop communism.
It's just like a few key cowboys.
Cowboys.
Yeah.
In anything.
Any cops,
right.
When you hear about corrupt cops,
that doesn't mean all cops are corrupt.
But did you ever see that doc documentary
on um,
New York?
Uh,
the seven five,
uh,
Mike Dowd,
he'd been a guest on Joey's podcast,
my podcast.
He was a corrupt cop and shit.
Deeply,
deeply,
deeply corrupt.
That means he murdered people.
No,
no,
no.
We've got up to that.
According to him,
he's never going to tell you he murdered people if didn't get caught for it.
But he went to jail and I,
he says he did.
And I believe him,
just to clarify,
but you know,
dealt with drug dealers and you know,
it was driving around in a corvette and shit like live in like a baller and
scary.
We're all selling drugs and they caught him and you know,
they put him in jail for a long time and then they put out this fucking amazing
documentary.
It's called the seven five.
It's,
what does he talk about?
Everything he tells them,
he spills the beans about getting involved with all these drug dealers and you
know,
rolling these people over,
taking their money and then go into business with them.
It's crazy.
It is crazy documentary.
You'll like,
you get anxiety even though,
you know the guy is still alive while they're telling the stories.
You're like Yeezus Christ.
They were just doing blow and going crazy and just,
and Robin people just straight Robyn people showing up at people's houses,
putting guns to their heads,
robbing other drug money,
you know,
like it was nuts,
man.
Like there was hits out on them.
It was crazy.
It's crazy.
It's a crazy documentary.
But this is like,
um,
there's a guy who I should know who the,
the current guest is on Sam Harris' podcast.
I'll look that up in a second.
But he was talking about it,
you know what they're talking about.
Like absolute power and absolute power.
Does that old expression absolute power corrupts absolutely.
Power corrupts and absolute power corrupts.
Absolutely.
And what they're talking about today,
and I was when I was walking the dog,
I was listening to this,
they were saying no,
what it does is it exposes you more than it corrupts you expose this corruption
and like in need.
He gave some examples about like Richard Nixon like that Richard Nixon when he
was,
when he was young,
his professor told them not to be a lawyer cause he has like really shitty
ethics.
Like expose him when he became president and that's when the power goes out to
them.
And that that's an interesting,
that's an interesting subject.
Like what does it like why does someone become out of control?
Corrupt cop?
Well it's a,
exposes them exposed to something in them.
But in his case when he was saying was the whole department was corrupt when he
got in there,
they were corrupt.
People were corrupt.
The day he got on the job,
people were telling him what to talk about,
what not to talk about,
and they beat some guy up or something like that.
And he's like,
this never,
this never happened.
You know,
like they have these little,
what do they call it?
What does that expression they have for um,
for cops keeping their mouth shut.
What the fuck is that?
What if there's an expression,
there's a,
there's like a code,
it's called the Coda says,
it's like almost has like snitches needs stitches like code of somebody.
I'm thinking of a Chuck Norris Movie Code of Silence.
But when you got the power to just rob drug dealers and you're,
you know,
a young guy was doing coke,
you're crazy.
He's a really nice guy though.
My Dad literally returned this police officer code of silence,
Cortisol South.
So Chuck Norris movie.
It wasn't Chuck Norris movie.
Right?
Good one.
That's a truck is doing those cop movies.
I love that shit.
When I was a kid.
Blue Wall of silence.
Anything coded,
all of that's coming up as I just kind of code of silence is the name of the
Chuck Norris movie.
Pretty sure.
But um,
yeah man,
I eat just like this corrupt cops.
Most cops aren't corrupt.
I think that's the case with agents with fucking anybody,
you know?
That's just how it goes,
man.
I have a bunch of cup friends.
They're all could just made a mad dash.
You know what's that?
That's what I would call it.
Diarrhea Dash.
Yep.
Running into that can,
I know there's cops out there that you know are probably a couple of them out
there.
Fucking people up and maybe a for sure.
For sure.
But the cops,
I know the cops that I come in contact with,
they've always been cool to me.
Yes.
Always been cooled them that well also too,
you know,
they're not pulling you over there.
Also in the martial arts,
you're a famous martial artist and a lot of times your training or learning from
them or what we were talking to them at UFC events and stuff in the south,
Sita Big John McCarthy.
Yup,
Yup.
Yeah.
It's like,
great guys.
I'm super pro cop,
but I know that there's bad people in every fucking line of work.
It doesn't mean cops are bad,
doesn't the cops.
It's a terrible fucking job.
The problem is when,
when someone does do something bad,
man,
it changes everybody's opinion about what cops are like.
This two videos I saw last week of cops pulling people over with guns drawn
pointed in the car.
One was a Mexican family,
a guy in his girl and one was a black family.
A guy in his girl is the same thing.
The guy's driving and the guy,
the cop has his gun out pointed at them and he's telling this,
a black kid to shut off his car and he's like,
I'm not going to do that.
He's like,
I'm not moving my hands.
He goes,
you give you give you an excuse to shoot me.
I'm not moving my hands.
So his girls filming it and he's got his hands up and it's crazy to watch,
man.
I don't know what happened before that.
I don't know what the context was.
I don't know.
I have no idea.
All I know is this guy's got a gun pointed at this guy and the guy's not
threatening him.
He's not sitting any and he's telling them to shut off the car and the guy's
scared and shut off the car.
Cause there are,
there are videos of a cop telling a guy pull over the guy he gets,
let me see your license registration and he reaches back to get his wallet and
the cop shoots him.
There's video though.
You can see that.
But what about just people is my point.
But I got to clarify.
I know the whole story.
You guys know the whole story.
They ran his plates and they go,
Oh shit we got to,
we got a hot one sometimes I'm sure that's never know.
Sometimes I'm sure that's the case,
but with this video that wasn't,
you know,
nobody provided that information in that video.
You just seeing the guy pointing a gun at a guy and I don't think he has his,
you know,
I mean,
he just has his hands up.
Look,
it's all fucking,
we've talked about this a hundred times.
It's a hard guy.
Damn job.
You're pulling people over.
You never know who's going to shoot you.
You want to go home to your wife and family and every fucking day you're pulling
people over the line to you every day you're dealing with people that are
breaking the law and they're not happy to see you every day.
And yeah,
I think that's where that absolute power corrupting comes in.
Corrupt some fucking people.
You know,
there's some,
some dirty birds out there.
I think in the future though,
ma'am,
you're going to see less and less of it.
I think it was probably 100% of the way things ran like many,
many years ago.
And now it's way less because it's just way more transparency.
And you know,
you know that cocaine cowboys documentary,
you seen that
Billy Corbin stuff?
Uh,
yes.
You know how the class of the graduating class,
the police academy in Miami,
one year,
100% of them either were murdered or went to jail for corruption the whole
class.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
But that's what happens when places go sideways.
You know when things go so nutty.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
Like the Scarface days.
Yeah.
That's how crazy I am.
If someone,
if someone told me to do,
you know,
the CIA,
Purdue,
Scarface,
to distract from their drug running,
I would just need a youtube link.
You know what I mean?
Well,
the CIA,
even if they didn't produce it,
if they really,
if some cowboys in the CIA were selling drugs,
even if they didn't produce Scarface,
they certainly benefited from it in somewhat because it made it made drug on
the,
for all the drug smugglers,
number,
all Cuban.
Never all Mexican,
like,
but it made it sound like there was some guys.
What was that guy?
Well,
didn't,
uh,
Barry seal bring in over 5 billion tons or 500 billion or $5 billion or
something like that.
A big billion.
Yeah.
Of Drug Money and cruise movie on him.
It wasn't that,
isn't that what it was about?
It was about that,
right?
Yeah.
And that's about,
it's about berries.
Yeah.
What is that movie called?
The Tom Cruise movie.
American mate.
That's a fucking excellent movie.
That's an excellent movie.
And for people who don't know how all that Shit went down and you watch that
movie,
I don't know how historically accurate it was because it involved,
the CIA told you talk about,
Oh yeah,
I may let that out.
Oh yeah.
And they essentially talk about exactly what we just talked about it cowboys and
the CIA and how many people were making money on the sneak tips son bringing in
that cocaine,
bringing in that yet.
I don't know if it had in the murders of the two kids though,
because that's really how they got busted.
They got busted because they were dropping off coke out of these planes and two
kids saw the drop off and they found the two kids near the coke and they fucking
murdered them.
And then they put him on train tracks and said they got high and fell asleep on
train tracks and p families,
uh,
did an autopsy and found knife wounds on the kid.
They knew something was up and then they investigated it.
And slowly but surely the,
the pieces started to fall apart.
And then when Barry seal was murdered,
he had George Bush his phone number in his pocket when he was murdered.
Is that in the movie too honest?
I don't know.
I don't know if that was in the movie,
but that's,
that's what happened on his way to testify.
I mean,
they weren't even hiding
it.
They just let this guy get shot up on the way to testify.
He for sure brought in a,
what I would call a fuck load of coke.
Who?
Barry Seal for sure.
A fuckload.
Who is his boss?
You think?
It's a good question.
It was an Arkansas,
right?
Somebody probably got a taste,
you know,
at many different stages.
Right?
What's the coke coming in?
Arkansas.
Mina,
right.
Mean ours.
That was that real was that movie Tom Cruise made a movie about Mena Arkansas
grow.
It's good movie.
I don't know.
It's hard for me to watch any movies unless it's an animated movie from my kid.
Like go into a regular movie can do it now.
It's hard.
Can't do it like I'm at home.
Well Google,
this was a,
we'd probably have a lot that we just covered that needs to be googled.
The website about the accuracy of the movie.
Oh good.
Perfect.
That's what I was gonna ask too.
Who decides how,
what's accurate or not?
Right,
right,
right.
And they let him go and certain certain times they caught him,
they let him go and people didn't want to let them go.
So like crazy documentary or crazy a movie.
But what do they call that?
Uh,
what a,
what a docu drama.
What is,
what does it,
when someone makes a movie about,
it's not really a docu drama though.
It's not,
it's a fucking movie.
It's like,
you know,
you never know how much is true.
Well,
we're talking about that goddamn wrestling movie with Steve Carell with a,
the Mark Hamill Mu or a Marka Schultes movie.
Oh yeah,
the Garrett gave and Marshall's.
Yeah,
the,
we carry Goodrich thing where they replaced him with some Russian dude in the
movie.
That's a historical event.
But Gary Goodrich fought Mark Schultz.
That was a historical event.
Marshall's dominated one of the best guys in the sport,
easily just wrestled him to the ground with ease.
And we got a chance to see,
wow,
this is what happens when an Olympic gold medalist wrestles a regular martial
artist.
But in the movie they decided to just change that for no reason.
Like they could do that with anything.
So who the fuck knows the Bruce Lee movie with Jason Scott Lee.
Yeah.
That was filled with a bunch of bull shit.
He's made shit up.
He had a famous fight where he learned wing Chung doesn't really work on
American's.
Yeah.
It was in a,
why MCA?
He was fighting for the right to teach foreigners Kung Fu.
Cause,
uh,
the elders that lived in San Francisco or Seattle,
I forget,
I think it's San Francisco.
Uh,
they didn't want him to teach foreigners and they said,
if you beat this,
if you beat our guy up,
then we'll let you teach foreigners.
So he had this fight and he was in the Ymcas,
but in the actual movie,
it's in a fucking dungeon.
Did it's like a kid just a cave and the elders or sit up like no.
Or The rings.
It's like fucking rings.
That's right.
It's the craziest,
they didn't have to go that far,
but I guess,
yeah,
it was just the YMC.
Did he win the fight?
Yes.
And he didn't use,
in real life,
he had a,
he hurt his back doing squats or dead lifts and really bad.
Here it is.
So that's when he wrote his first book is when he was like in traction.
Is that what they call it when they get your backs and some kind of spinal or
some kind of brace,
but,
so,
but in the movie,
the dude kicked him in the back and broke his back.
Uh,
yeah.
Tricky.
Yeah.
Alone.
And then he's,
there's a famous appearance of his at the Long Beach Convention Center back in
the 60s.
It was like a karate tournament and he did some demonstrations.
He did that.
There's a,
there's video famous video of him doing the one inch punch.
It's in front of,
it's like at the,
like an IB,
Jj have tournament.
He's doing a demonstration.
And in the movie it was a real fight and he fights the same dude from the
dungeon.
It's a rematch.
Oh No,
they made that.
They added on.
Who the fuck are you guys thinking?
Why would they do that?
They didn't need to,
his life was amazing in,
you know,
in reality.
Aren't they doing something on him right now though?
Isn't something happening right now?
Some new Bruce Lee thing that I read that or am I just hoping there's a movie
coming out about a dude who was a famous actor in the late sixties and early
seventies and in the movie
he's,
Oh,
he's a stud man.
Yeah.
He's a famous rich duck man dude.
And,
uh,
in the movie there's a Bruce Lee part where he's in a Bruce Lee movie and also a
movie called once upon a time in Hollywood.
He showed that's it there.
Yeah.
Oh,
nice.
But it's not,
is it CGI Bruce Sleep,
nor is it an actor.
It's an act.
They should have went with the CGI Bruce.
Oh,
how cool.
Would that make a new Bruce Lee movie all CGI?
They could do that shit here.
Imagine now Illuminati doesn't want you to know how good they are at that yet.
Okay.
So if the Illuminati creative,
Bruce Lee,
what would be the reason?
Well,
they would,
if they did it,
they would let you know,
hey,
fuck face.
We already can make movies at a anybody.
Anytime we want,
we are going to have someone talking like Bruce Lee.
Look at that.
Wait a minute.
That looks like Bruce Lee did.
It looks very good.
Was that CGR doesn't look like I'm right there.
I mean,
it's close enough.
Is that the new Bruce Lee?
This is just,
Oh,
they from the trailer is that only piece we can go?
you know what,
that CGI,
no.
Okay.
No,
no,
it's not.
No,
no,
no.
For sure.
It's CGI.
That first scan,
that first clip down,
right?
Their CTO,
it's glasses and he's wearing glasses face.
He's already looks fake as fuck.
It looks like a CGI video game thing that they did something to his jaw.
It little bit looks like a Cgi face,
so he has an unusual looks real,
but that's cause you're seeing them at a different angle.
Watch backing up to where he's at the side.
What if they're doing like that thickening to me?
Hold on,
hold on me.
That looks Jesus Christ already to find job.
His job he's getting.
I know you got to stop.
You gotta stop.
It's exhausting.
Um,
could have though,
if they wanted to get in the fast and furious with Paul Walker created his face
a lot.
Well they needed to do a Bruce Lee movie.
They can't have it fucked up at all.
It has to be super smooth.
It has to be.
It has to be really.
Bruce Lee ask.
Totally.
And you know what?
You could do it like that movie man.
This was like 20 years ago,
the final fantasy movie where they did animation but they tried to make it look
real old people.
They got that shit down.
They got old people
down harder and make a young girl look real.
So that kind of ad is still a cartoon effect.
But older people should look like real people.
Yeah,
they can do it with textured skins,
right?
You do it with dragons and that was 20 years ago.
They could do movies that are full CGI.
That's really hard to tell.
Well,
it's also because your brain doesn't have like a reference point for dragons.
They can make a dragon look real where it's like,
did you see game of Thrones when they have the wolves?
The wolves are always just like,
eh,
the hair move.
They don't have a haircut.
They're like five years away from here.
It moves to to CGI.
Slow Mo.
Yeah.
It's always super slow mo.
That is him that popped up here on this video thinking Michael Moe,
that's the dude.
So when you see him with the glasses and see him from the side,
um,
he should.
Uh,
that's interesting.
I don't know if they could do the CGI yet for a whole movie and make him with
Bruce Lee's face.
I can do it.
Perfect.
Wow,
that's crazy.
So they could have done that.
But then again,
if everybody else in the movie isn't like Steve Mcqueen and all the other famous
folks in the movie,
like are they using different people for them or that that would be fucked up.
Imagine if in the future all they ever make is like Charles Bronson movies,
Steve McQueen movies,
Bruce Lee movies.
And they do it with regular actors in the regular actors get paid like scale and
these are giant ass when they do face to face getting on them.
And they have new Bruce Lee movies and they have some dudes
how rogue they added a princess Leia back was not even alive anymore.
I didn't see the new one.
Yeah,
there you go.
Maybe I did.
Is that the ones where they're doing it now?
She's in the more recent one that just came out.
And the one before that too,
I guess.
I think I saw the most,
what's the most recent?
There's a lot of them.
Yeah.
I think I'm,
I think I'm one behind.
I think I missed,
I haven't seen the new Avengers.
I didn't manage to avoid the whole spoiler when they start doing like,
uh,
like they'll take Angela Jolena leaves face and has her own leave and put it on
like a,
you know,
Beyonce,
his body or something.
You remember that song?
See that big old titties like Angelina's y'all lean.
I mean that song.
Yeah.
It's a great song.
That was a big hit for like a couple of weeks about that.
Yeah.
Angelina Jolie got some big ass titties.
That was the song.
That was the whole,
it was like different people that had some big ass titties.
That was the name of the song.
Um,
she's in that new maleficent movie.
They did some crazy shit to her face,
man.
They turned her into some like Dragon Lady's some wizard lady or which,
yeah,
there's a lot of satanism in movies,
man.
They go dark with the,
do you trip out?
I know,
I know.
Uh,
we have different opinions on like,
you know,
like the sky and space,
but do,
do you notice,
do you notice watching kids programming that they fucking bombard kids with
space,
right?
Sure.
Dude.
Hey,
they get hammered with it in every movie there
space,
there's aliens are space.
There's aliens.
They get bought movies.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
It's insane.
They blasted with it.
Well,
there's a lot above us.
If you look at what's important for kids now,
totally important.
Period.
Man.
I went to see Brian Cox's demonstration that he did.
They did like to do a show.
I did it a in downtown La and I was thinking I would love to get Eddie Bravo
high and have him watch this like a fight companion.
This is CGI.
Is this fake?
Yeah.
Why do you think it's fake?
How much do you think is fake that you see in space?
Man?
Um,
you know,
Wernher von Braun was a Nazi,
right?
Yes.
Okay.
He was brought in from operation paperclip,
right?
Right.
We had Annie Jacobson on.
Did you listen to that?
Yeah.
She talked in depth about that.
I mean,
that's how everyone agrees on that.
Everyone agrees that he directed all six moon missions.
Yup.
Everyone agrees.
Everyone agrees that him and Walt Disney,
we're best friends where they grow best friends,
they're best friends.
They worked on space together.
Um,
[inaudible] they were like,
you know,
jump into a lot of conclusions today.
In this day and age,
you don't think anybody's like when space x shoots rockets off in this space or
when,
you know,
Amazon has a rocket company.
Now these guys are going to be able to launch satellites and even have consumer
flights.
I just need proof,
man.
What about deception?
I see a lot of future.
Would you be willing option everywhere?
So I'm like,
okay.
You know,
when you're talking about you're moving,
hold on.
You know,
you're talking about that Foxcatcher movie or like you've said a couple times on
your podcast where you're like,
once you've,
once you saw that they left Gary Goodridge out,
you were like,
I can't trust this movie.
I can't try the whole movies.
I can't trust that.
It may be real.
It may not be real,
but I need some proof.
I got you.
That's exactly how I feel about
that space.
The government,
the government coming from a government agency,
whatever.
It's a government agency.
I look at it like Fox catcher.
You've lied enough where I'm like,
I need some irrefutable evidence.
Otherwise,
why do I have to believe it?
I just assume any real I you don't get it,
but space x is in the government space.
Private company.
No,
they're subsidized by the government man.
Subsidized do they got like $4 billion.
So they tell them the fake space.
No one's trusting national more so they're handing it over.
Hey,
let's,
let's get,
let's do the side thing and everyone's all in space now.
That's,
that's the way to look at it.
I think it's when you saw the,
you saw that,
that Tesla lunch,
you saw that.
What are you talking about when you launched,
when he claim to launch a toaster,
did you see that footage?
The actual Teslin space?
Yes.
I saw that.
And you have a dude,
you've,
I've always known you as a dude,
had a strong,
vibrant,
vibrant bullshit meter.
You've always been that game,
you're going to watch that evidence and go,
oh,
okay.
You can't just buy that dude.
You can't just buy that.
Let me ridiculous elements.
The very first thing,
the very first day,
the very first don't poison the water.
She wanted me to get an honest
react first.
Elon Musk set on his,
in his press conference,
the first thing he said is like,
well,
I think it's impossible and ridiculous and,
and uh,
if um,
you can tell it's real because it looks so fake.
That's the opposite of logic.
There's logic and reason and then there's the opposite of that.
No,
we can tell it's real because it looks so fake is the opposite of of words.
That's just something he says because he's a fucking genius and he's taken a
picture from.
But the reason why he said no,
no,
the reason he said that was because all day when they did that all day,
all over the Internet with like fake,
fake,
fake something.
He had to have a statements.
Please hold her.
She had Java statement.
This is so ridiculous.
Let me see it,
Jamie.
Come on,
let me see the video.
Which one?
When fucking the Tesla and space.
I know Tesla and space.
Our video,
which is just get a short one.
Just go you just Tesla and space and you're gonna pick the wrong one that got
edited.
So I'm trying to find the one that's from space.
We could just abandon this up.
So for,
you know what,
I just,
it may be real space x maybe real exactly why,
you know,
seen him shoot the rockets off.
I mean,
literally people,
when you look at it and tell me she'll rocket,
anytime you see a rocket shoot,
you see it go up and then you go down into the ocean,
they launch rockets,
they're launching rockets.
That's what it looks like.
Because what you're seeing it go over the curve of the earth.
Eddie,
you're seeing it go over the ocean.
You've seen it go up and over.
And so as it gets further away that you can't see it anymore,
it looks like it's going to be going up.
The nods going parallel to the ground.
It's not going parallel to the right.
Okay.
So they're shooting fucking space.
They are sharing it spinning.
Okay.
I,
I understand that.
That's what you believe,
but you got to understand why I believe what I believe because,
because that's what you see.
But if you have someone explain it to you,
what you still believe it.
Um,
if you have a scientist,
explain.
No,
no,
no physics.
We're not no nation,
no explanation.
I need evidence.
You need evidence.
And then when you see evidence,
when you see that Tesla that they launched and you see how fake it looks,
it looks so fantastic.
But just because something doesn't look real,
it doesn't mean it's fake.
But it doesn't mean it's real.
I need evidence.
I need to have a look at them.
You see that you haven't seen with your own eyes might be fake.
Maybe.
I don't trust you.
Don't trust that everybody's like a simulation.
You know,
I had a friend who lied about everything,
everything about his life,
where he was from,
all the things he did.
He was a wrestling champion.
He was,
uh,
he,
he had everything.
Then I found out like two years into the relationship,
little by little that he lied about this and he lied about that.
Then I find out that he lied about everything.
He's one of those guys that learn lies about everything and you the government.
Exactly.
So he may be telling the truth and even total liars will tell the truth
throughout the day a lot just to get through the day that you have to tell the
truth to get,
but then you know at the drop of a hat they're going to lie about their life in
some crazy way.
Whatever.
I understand your logic,
Eddie,
he me slow you down here.
That's,
I understand your logic,
but you also have to assume that most of the people that are telling you the
truth about this or that online,
that also don't have proof that also are talking about these things and they
haven't shown you.
You haven't seen it.
You haven't been there just like you haven't been,
you know,
examining satellites,
these people,
they,
you don't know if they're full of shit either.
It could be a real,
that could be,
it could be that they were,
why would you assume they were?
But the satellites are fake.
See what I'm saying?
What do you mean?
[inaudible] people that are making these youtube videos that they're correct,
but the people that are putting up satellites are bullshit.
Go by science.
That's what scientific evidence like real science,
like water is always level,
right?
We know that water is always level at a hundred miles in the conversation.
If you don't understand how gravity works over a giant fucking sphere,
if,
if we live on a ball that's $25,000 if we do,
then the water should be bending.
So stop with this.
This is so crazy.
You don't even know what that means.
I do know if it's a ball,
the ocean should be curving at a certain rate and they figured that out.
Here's the power of perspective yet,
but it's going around.
Why?
Why is it going over the top and why does it shrink at the end?
Everything.
You look at the end of the street as streetlights do that.
Yeah,
but it does streetlights do that.
That's called personal 80.
They did that on the hill.
Not on the ocean.
No,
no,
but you're looking at those,
uh,
electrical posts or whatever you call them and they go down.
That's how street like you go right in the middle of the street.
The very next streetlight is,
appears to be shorter than that one.
And then the next one appears to be short.
That's how you draw shit you.
But is it really that short?
No,
it's just your perspective.
You're actually looking at an optical illusion.
You're actually looking at,
it looks like they're getting shorter and descending.
It looks,
but are they?
No,
they're not.
Because if you went up and Eddie,
they disappear.
They disappear over the horizon and then you could bring them back in.
But that's not true.
Now you can,
you know,
you can see more up to the edge of the horizon.
But if he owed to the horizon,
it goes over the door.
The,
so when you're talking about win win with the naked eye,
you're looking at a moan,
go in the ocean and you see it open.
Their is a really telescopes will.
You're just getting small enough so that you can't see it anymore.
That if you use the telescope you can still see it for a little while and then
it goes over the fucking curb and they're a more powerful tell us,
go now.
It brings it even closer,
but you yet have more power.
Otherwise everybody had tests they've already done.
You could see England,
you could look out at,
you could see Hawaii too much.
You could see Hawaii.
Then I can't.
You see Hawaii.
If you could see the moon,
why can't you see how there's a lot of atmospheric curves?
The fuck,
you know,
fit curves.
Okay.
That's what the scientists say.
Eddie,
the ones who make the GPS,
the ones that make the maps,
the ones who chart the fucking paths for airplanes and shipping routes.
All those people say it's around all the people that do satellites.
All the people that are involved in aerospace,
all the people that are involved in anything where you have to calculate the
fucking curve or the earth and the the the to get things to places.
All those people think it.
They're all wrong.
That's crazy that they haven't seen that picture,
that they don't.
They don't see that picture.
If they saw the picture,
they would get it
at a hundred miles in the ocean.
A hundred miles.
How much curvature should they be?
Do you know?
I don't care.
It's about 6,000 feet.
It's about 6,000 feet of curvature,
so you shouldn't have said how far you can see.
No,
you wouldn't be able to see a hundred miles away from the oceans.
Who?
Eddie,
you didn't go to school for this stuff.
These people don't understand too.
You did I research these all the time?
No,
but you're hearing,
you're hearing for what?
Do you know what I'm saying?
You're at a hundred miles.
There should be 6,000 feet of curvature.
Do you don't even understand what that means?
I don't.
I understand what that means.
If we live on a ball that at every hundred miles there should be 6,000 feet of
curvature.
There's,
there's a formula for it and,
but when you look,
there's a navy ships that can target other navy ships with lasers a hundred
miles away.
It would be impossible if it that was a 6,000 foot curvature of water.
Impossible.
They take pictures of their target pictures at a hundred miles.
There's no curvature.
It's flat.
There should be 6,000 feet from the pictures of what?
Eddie,
this is something,
this is not your area of expertise.
This is one of the reasons why I get crazy about this kind of shit.
Dude.
I look into this box because you read something that someone said,
I know that you can just be what I just said.
You can't just be what I just said.
I bet you can even go to school for it.
So I don't know,
but I bet.
Do you understand?
Do you stand up?
We live on a ball at a hundred feet.
There should be 6,000 feet of curvature.
Does that make sense to everyone's wrong,
Eddie?
So all these fucking people,
does that make sense?
Sound Australia,
they're doing it the wrong way.
All these people that go over the North Pole.
All that's all that's snow goes,
goes into lines.
There's no flights over the North Pole.
There's no flight batteries.
Maybe there's military planes to go over the North Pole.
Maybe.
Okay,
let's please this shit.
I've flown all over the world.
I've never gotten over the North Pole.
I found everywhere in everywhere.
I've never,
no one ever goes over the North Pole so it doesn't mandate go over the notes.
I Dunno.
So painful.
It's so painful.
This change the subject.
I'm trying to change the subject.
We can talk about Tony Ferguson Saturday.
What about that?
That's great.
You got any questions?
What you've been working with them?
Fuck yeah.
Fuck yeah,
dude.
He's,
he's sharper,
stronger in the best shape of his life.
It's the same Tony that,
um,
you know,
you'd think like,
is it going to be the same Tony after,
you know,
the,
he had,
he had some,
uh,
you know,
family stuff go on.
Is,
is that going to change him?
You know,
um,
uh,
his opponents hope it changes him,
but he is,
he's the same Tony.
When it comes to fighting,
we don't get into personal stuff.
We just stick to fighting the strategy.
He
sharper than ever.
It's not,
you know,
you can't guarantee any wins,
but I will guarantee that he's going to go win 100% Tony.
It's crazy.
Matchups very good match.
That's like Russian roulette right there,
dude.
They're going to be throwing bombs at each other.
It's real good.
Particularly now with Donald has been on a tear like the last four fights,
three,
four fights.
I mean,
he's just looked so good man.
The ally quantify for people who know how good allies for Donald to handle al
like that and drop him and you know,
and really put it to them like the way I'll put it.
I mean,
Al said he beat the shit out of me.
I told I was exact quote was and I was very complimentary and respectful after
the fight to cowboy is no joke.
That guy's on fire racing.
He doesn't fight like Khabib.
He doesn't fight like Connor.
He fights like Tony,
so it's like similar.
It's like telling versus Tony,
you know what I mean?
And it's a shit due to both get on the ground.
They're very good on the ground and we respect cowboys fucking ground game a
lot.
And you know,
we,
um,
you know,
we did what we could to make sure,
nothing bad happens on the ground,
you know what I mean?
But they both have everything.
Yeah.
They both have great striking.
They both have great submissions.
Tony's coming for war,
like he always does.
It's going to be the same tone throwing down,
that's for sure.
Did.
Now,
when Tony,
let me ask you this,
cause you know the answer to this,
when Tony had his knee fixed,
did he spar during that camp because someone said that he didn't do any
sparring.
It was like one of the rumors from someone who knew him.
Um,
I think he keeps his sparring,
uh,
you know,
talking about striking,
right?
Yes.
I'm never there for the striking.
Oh,
I've never had separate.
We don't,
I'm never,
I've never seen him.
Um,
uh,
I'm never there for the striking.
I only show us when there's grappling his,
the,
the amount of time that it took him into her cover in big bear.
He didn't,
we didn't bring anybody to spar like hardcore.
It was just like lights touching because of the needs.
Letting the knee heel.
Oh no,
that a different fight.
I'm talking about the knee.
Remember you had the massive knee entry and then he had surgery and then what I
heard during the pedals fight.
Oh yeah,
no sparring.
No spine.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
Very light.
Hmm.
Well I guess,
you know,
when you already world class you could do that and find a guy.
I mean,
he didn't want to fuck with it.
Wanting to make sure that nothing went wrong.
Get to the,
get to the fight.
It was that it was the right choice for sure.
And when he showed up against pedis,
you looked like same old Tony.
He did that.
It was stunning.
Vicious.
You're talking about a catastrophic knee injury.
And then six months later he's fighting a world class fighter and he's getting
his legs checked.
You know,
he got the,
that need check too.
We even worried at one point in time that he might be injured.
What makes Tony so good?
In my opinion,
just based on working with them is it seems that,
um,
you know,
at,
at the highest level,
high pressure fight,
people are,
aren't as,
uh,
the more cautious.
They don't want to try and do anything stupid.
They're not fucking just letting it swing and letting it go.
Tony isn't like that.
Tony is,
people want to get to the point where they just unleash and they don't give a
fuck.
And there's a lot of fighters like that,
but Tony,
when he's in there,
it's like,
like Nick Diaz,
they're not afraid to throw anything.
You know what I mean?
He goes in there,
he'll throw two spinning elbows in a row and he's just having fun.
It's like he's alive and he's having fun in there and he's,
and on the ground,
he's not going to be hesitant to do something wild and crazy.
That's just the way his man,
and he thrives in the cage and there's zero hold back.
He's,
he's,
he comes out guns a blazing the whole time.
Yeah,
they're both at the top of their game,
man,
that's for sure.
You know,
and Tony didn't miss a step when he got that knee injury,
which was very impressive.
Even in striking was on point when he fought pedis.
Yeah.
And even got tested.
He got clipped and pet has hurt him,
you know,
he knows how to survive.
Man.
He's a very unusual fighter man.
Very difficult to prepare for because studying,
always studying,
always adding new weapons to his arsenal.
Always adding something to is a workout routine.
He's always adding shit.
He has the ability to focus more than anybody.
I know.
He his his ability to focus.
And you see that not only in,
you know,
the striking aspect of his game or the rest of what you see it in the Jujitsu
and that's where I see it is he has so much focus.
He doesn't,
I don't have to reteach them shit.
I will show them have very complicated transition of moves.
Like,
you know,
in spider web doing the Ballinger break,
there's like four moves you've got to do.
You've got to fire them.
It's gotta be so smooth.
They can't be any fuck ups.
And I show him this and after like four or five reps,
he's got it down.
And most people,
it takes,
it takes six months to get it down to understand it.
And he just can,
he just,
um,
doesn't take him long to learn shit.
Anything wrestling,
striking,
anything new,
he's down.
Uh,
but he doesn't forget it.
That's the most important thing.
He remembers all this shit.
And um,
you know,
it's,
so who's working with him with striking?
A guy named Rashad used to,
I think he was a like an Olympic hopeful back in the day.
Boxer.
Yeah.
Most guys do that,
right?
Yeah.
It seems like there's not a lot of guys who just use one for all striking.
He's got a bunch of people that train them.
He's got a couple of different strength and conditioning coaches.
Um,
he's got a whole crew man I got,
that's important.
And he's mostly bossing to really into recovery.
Like he spends a serious time recovering.
He's got all these contraptions,
you know,
those things that you can,
they're like leg sleeves from a text and they inflate and he's on that all the
time.
He's like,
yeah,
he's sh when it comes to rehab for any injury,
he's like,
like a professional NFL player,
you know.
And um,
ice baths,
like,
you know,
at massages.
He doesn't fuck around man.
He's,
he's 100%
thinking about and doing something for the fight.
Usually just nonstop.
He can go on for hours.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
It's fucking crazy matchup.
But it's only the third fight.
I mean,
it's the third from the top,
you know,
there's two championship fights on top of that.
That's crazy.
That should be the headliner right there.
Come on,
man.
That fight's going to be nuts.
People going to go crazy for that.
She's great.
But so Hutto and Marlin,
more eyes have to fight for the bantamweight title.
That's a crazy fight too,
man.
So Hutto Mariah's that's the main event.
And then a Valentina Shevchenko and Jessica I for the,
uh,
women's flyway title.
So those are two world title fights.
They have to have those.
At the top,
but that just shows you how fucking crazy the card is.
The card from top to bottom.
It's just amazing.
Yeah,
it's going to be crazy.
Fucking him.
Jimmy,
Jimmy Rivera and Pyotr Jaan tied to advisee and blogged knee.
I've enough you moving it while I was trying to read it.
Don't do the up,
bro.
That's rude.
Fuck up.
That dude's name tied to evolve as a animal.
Those are,
that's a great fucking fight.
That guy is crazy.
That's that guy that drinks out of a shoe.
He ever see him do that.
He does.
Shoeys he pours beer into shoes and the other people's shoes to like tell
someone to take their shoes off.
He pours beer into their shoes and then drinks it.
Oh my God.
It's so disgusting.
It's so foul.
Yeah.
I don't get it,
but I get it.
He likes to party.
He's like that dude in Talladega nights.
What the fuck's his name?
Um,
the other guy.
John C.
Reilly.
Yeah.
John Rise like party.
I like to party.
It likes to drink out of shoes.
Fuck it.
He's an animal.
I guess.
Like,
I mean if you want to really show you don't give a fuck,
that's a good way to go about doing it.
Just grab a man's shoe and pour a beer and do it and drink it.
It's dirty,
sweaty feet have and fucking around.
Imagine if you died from that measure of someone's foot.
Fungus was so disgusting that even the alcohol didn't kill it.
It germinated inside your gut where foot fungus is never going to be like if,
if there's venereal diseases,
right?
When we all know there are because you dirty bitch,
like what?
What?
What are you guys doing to each other?
You're both giving each other dirty fucking things with dirty things and that
diseases are weird,
right?
People give each other disease this venereal diseases which are extra weird.
It's like,
oh,
you dirty people.
He gave each of these dirty,
dirty disease,
but nature of says,
we don't like this nature.
Just let these sneaky little parasites and viruses and bacteria getting your
body.
What if there was an even more powerful one for people?
Sucked on feet?
What if it got into your gut?
Nature's like this guy is just too much of a freak.
We got to call them column for the herd if like if there was foot sucking
diseases,
you know before you make out with someone,
you got to tell them,
hey,
I just want you to know I've got a foot socking disease.
So,
uh,
if you don't,
maybe we shouldn't do this.
But Jamie,
what do you making faces for?
Says you can get staff from doing this.
Of course you can.
Science skins firms shoeys are really freaking dangerous,
especially if you're rich.
Why is it more dangerous?
Yeah,
that's cliquey.
But they try to get us with the clickbait.
Turns out you can get staffed.
Yeah,
you can get staff.
Don't do it.
I don't get a science study to figure that out.
Yeah.
Because because the staff,
Aurora's can cause toxins and these toxins are quite resistant to heat.
They are quite resistant to the acidic environment when they can survive a
protein breaking enzymes.
Oh Jesus Christ.
If you drink from someone shoe containing staff and its toxins,
yes,
it can give you an acute gastro intestinitis fuck all that says.
But alcohol's a disaffected,
right?
Well,
yes,
but there's always still a risk of infection,
especially if you have lower abv,
alcohol by volume drinks as you'd expect.
Higher abv drinks like vodka do a much better job of rack or radicating
bacteria.
So yeah,
beer,
which is what they drank,
which is a low alcohol beer or low alcohol beverage.
What a fucked up way to die.
Die.
You've got to do shots and those things will,
shots are fine.
Oh my God.
People are crazy.
But no one's happy with like taking it and leaving it where it is.
Everybody wants to take it to the next level.
You know,
like everyone constantly like you want to one up somebody,
I'm going to drink out of the underwear,
bro.
I'm gonna use your underwear as a fucking filter.
No dude are going to do undies.
They going to be ripping each other's underwear off and using them over a
filter.
Put it over a glass and drink right through your underwear.
How did that cat coffee get found out that Kopi Luwak good idea because some
asshole decided to pick cat shit and find beans in it.
It's a,
it's a cat like animal,
right?
It's called a civet.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You ever had that shit that Kopi Luwak coffee.
It's very expensive.
Tate and I got it once.
We were at a Gig in Florida.
Tate.
Yeah.
It was like $100 a cup of coffee or something stupid.
It was really ridiculous.
Not that much.
Maybe 25 bucks.
I don't remember when he was bodyguards calm.
Yeah.
Back in the day.
That's the animal.
Look at that thing.
So that thing eats the coffee beans.
It shits them out and then people pull it out of the poop payday.
It looks like a little person.
Look the things baby like the thing for fantastic four.
It looks like his baby.
Yeah.
They pulled those beans out of the poop and then they uh,
they dry them off and make coffee out of catch shit and a,
it tastes delicious because what it is is the Diet.
Look at that.
That's gold,
right?
There was gold coming out of that cat's ass hole.
We'll give that.
That is a ridiculous,
you could just see that online.
Um,
taking a lar,
like if that was a person,
you'd be in jail,
right?
If you,
if you went and googled that person shitting on a log like that,
he'd be like,
you sick.
Fuck.
Long as it's an animal,
it's to look at their shit and even mine it,
they mind their shit for beans.
The idea is that the digestive enzymes from the civets body breakdown,
the,
uh,
the beans,
the coffee beans,
that's the idea.
And you liked it.
It was okay,
aren't you?
Wasn't better.
It's not bad out here for the guests,
it's not better.
The idea is that it's supposed to be smoother and smoother.
This catch it,
coffee smoother.
I don't know,
man.
I don't necessarily think it really is smoother.
It's just different.
Some weird shit.
I wonder if you could just eat the cat shit just like that without cleaning it
off if you were really nasty.
Yeah.
The natives probably just used to eat the cat should directly.
It probably did,
but I think you need to have energy.
You probably need a boil it.
That's why a,
when you're making coffee in that boiling water probably kills all the bad
stuff.
You know,
they blow.
Did the Indians boil shit.
I want to know.
I don't know who invented that shit and how long it's been around that shit
literal.
Literally who invented that coffee.
Okay.
How long it's been around spinner.
I'm looking at it right now.
Wikipedia.
Since like the 18 hundreds,
they noticed that these particular animals were eating specific cherries or
whatever,
that they were leaving around and that they were going on digested.
So at some point they decided to clean it off and see how it tasted,
I guess.
Fucking risk.
Hmm.
Um,
I was listening to my friend Ryan Callahan's podcast today.
It's a cow's weekend review and he was talking about this animal that they,
um,
this bird rather that people eat and they drowned.
This bird in brandy,
they take this little tiny bird.
Each one of them is like just a few ounces and they drowned them in brandy.
And then when you eat them,
you eat them whole,
you need everything.
The guts you eat,
the tissue,
the skin.
That's,
that's,
that's where it is.
Um,
what is the name of it?
What,
how do,
how do I pronounce it for Dalon Bunting Order Lawn.
And so when you eat it,
you put a Napkin over your head.
Traditionally when they eat it and as they eat it.
Bordain was the first one to tell me about this shit that,
oh no,
it was Duncan.
Duncan Trussell was the first person to tell me about the shit and the suddenly
Bourdain love,
they soak the bird in brand.
They drown it.
Okay.
They drown it in brandy and then they cook it somehow or another.
But anyway,
go back to that picture where those guys are eating it.
Where you could see the,
go back to the picture with the,
yeah.
See how they have those things over their head.
They put these napkins over their head to taking the aromas and to trap the
aromas.
And they also do it to hide their face from God.
Those,
the idea.
Yeah.
Kind of people are these,
I think it's most,
I think it's Europeans.
I think it's,
uh,
something that in,
in France it's popular,
it's popular dish.
And,
um,
it's,
it's endangered.
Not endangered now,
but there.
Yeah,
that's okay.
Order lawns.
Could Francis crew was food be back in the menu as French chefs lobby for order
lawn to be reintroduced onto menus.
We explain why cooking the rare and delicate song bird is so controversial.
So that's even grosser,
right?
It's a song bird.
Like how they named it a song bird not,
it's not a little tiny dinosaur.
No,
no,
no.
It's a song bird.
It just wants to sing for you.
Make the woods bright.
Uh,
tweet,
tweet.
Nah Man,
it's a weird little tiny animal says why is it illegal to cook and kill an
ordeal on the R S P B list their status as vulnerable.
And throughout the 1970s in 1980s,
numbers in France declined dramatically as poachers caught vast numbers to
supply restaurants where the bird has long been considered rare and expensive
delicacy.
Some restaurants would charge over 50 pounds for the dish.
What does that in,
um,
is that euros or pounds,
pounds,
pounds.
What do you think that costs?
What's 50 pounds?
Is that like 100 bucks?
Not quite,
but something like that.
Frances League for the protection of birds claimed a order lawn numbers plunged
30% between 97 and 2007 as many as 1,500 poachers catching an estimated 30,000
live birds a year.
So they're just decimating these fucking things.
Um,
the method of capturing,
killing them as what's fucked up about it.
So the hunters catch the birds using traps in the fields.
Uh,
they're kept in cages,
uh,
encouraging them to gorge on grain in order to double their size.
And it said the Roman emperors stabbed out their eyes in order to make the birds
think it was night.
Making them eat even more.
Oh,
okay.
Here it goes.
And then how were they killed?
This is where the squeamish look away.
What is the name of his websites?
We give People Telegraph autograft from the Telegraph.
What does the name of the article?
Well,
we'll tell,
we'll say it at the end.
Uh,
how were they killed?
Says this is where the squeamish need to look away.
Traditionally in France,
the fat and little birds are drowned in a vat of our mock neck.
I guess that's like a tiger cognac or something.
What does that are magnetic?
Probably you're probably dead on with.
Okay.
Managing to snuff out their lives in marinate them at the same time,
killing two birds with one glug as it were.
It says here in the article,
French chefs argue that it's not a bad way to die in quotes.
What the fuck?
But I suppose it might be less cruel than throwing a live lobster into a pot of
boiling water anyway,
so that's how they drown.
They drown them and then they cook them and then you eat the whole fucking
thing.
Bones and all and the bones puncture your mouth and shit.
And that's part of it.
Like you taste your own blood as you're eating these fucking things.
Yeah.
People are weird,
man.
You leave them alone for long enough.
Let him get drunk and buy things.
Reminds me of that Andrew Schultz bit that he put on Youtube,
which one?
The eating and he goes,
if you eat ass,
you should not complain about other people's food.
None of my friends,
my friend told me,
he goes,
hey,
you know in Thailand they crickets.
He goes,
I eat ass cause they're eating crickets because they have no food.
My refrigerator's full.
So true too.
He's so good,
dude.
He's,
he's so good.
That's my new favorite dude.
This,
he's awesome.
Really,
really nice guy.
Too dirty as hell.
Yeah.
You meet him at went next time he's at the store.
The love him.
He's a real comic.
It's a real deal.
Oh he's high level is high level.
What is his driver Tony to try and Tony and we're listening to Andrew Schultz.
Oh that's cool.
Yeah,
I love that guy.
He's great.
And he also is one of the few that is doing the youtube thing now.
Why you decided to release all this shit on Youtube?
Yeah,
yeah.
Thank God.
Giving me some,
you know,
entertainment very well.
It's also very smart for him.
I mean he's getting millions and millions of views on youtube.
It's blown up.
Yeah.
Oh for sure.
He's killing it.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
you know,
to have it available anytime they say that kids watch 50% of Netflix on their
phone,
50%,
at least that was,
I think that was the numbers they gave me.
Um,
I think that was what they said about my special 50% across the board for what
it takes.
Take your pick,
remove Netflix,
youtube,
50% twitch,
50% website,
50%.
But that's the,
the switcheroo though it was 50% watch on their phone.
That could be watching on the computer.
But how many of them watched on the TV?
Like with Youtube it's probably a pretty small percentage,
right?
Switches because they,
they're tracking,
they stay splinter it between like an Xbox or ps four what?
Smart TV or watch youtube on my TV near that shit.
Yeah,
I do.
I do that sometimes I mirror that and I also,
there's a,
youtube is one of the other apps.
It's built into the TV I bought.
So you can get Netflix right from your TV.
You don't have to have an apple TV and youtube right from your TV.
It's um,
it's interesting how big it is now.
It's so big.
Youtube is gigantic.
They got a bunch of movies on there now.
I just,
I was watching it on my TV and just like scrolling through to see what I could,
what it was going to give me and it's like you're making their own with ads.
They were making their own movies but it's weird to like,
it seems like you don't know where to search.
Like what did,
did you just go into the search bar and just search?
Just type things up.
I see my subscription,
I subscribed to certain people and I just go to this.
This is not what it means.
Yeah.
I know I do that too.
But I mean like if they make a movie like they were making movies,
like how do you find that movie?
They got a pop up different right in your face.
They own that shit.
But if it's a movie that they make,
like I wonder how I would like to know the numbers.
Like have they,
how many times did they done that?
Cause they made youtube originals,
right?
Like they made their,
they finance their own.
Most of them are shows though,
like,
uh,
like the,
the one that I know has done the best is that Cobra Kai could second the second
or third season.
I think it's not weird though,
that they get into the production side of it.
Like they're already a place where people produce things and then put them on
youtube and youtube was like,
yeah,
we're going to make her own shit.
But then they become something different.
Right,
because they're
going to,
they're going to favor their own stuff above your stuff if you make a movie too.
Yeah.
They haven't made like why bother?
I think they just want to,
I mean I think that's what every company,
every company gets into this position where they have to constantly expand.
They've got to constantly be kicking ass,
you know,
and,
and no,
no one wants to be stagnant.
They don't want the quarterly earnings to be the same every quarter.
That's us.
That's a bad sign.
They want to be out there killing it.
Right.
They'll take take like that.
Like every company thinks like that.
[inaudible] finals is currently sponsored by a Youtube TV.
That's on normal TV.
They're broadcasting watch TV on Youtube TV,
which is pretty counterintuitive.
I have it.
I have youtube TV every now and then you need to watch something on a regular
channel.
I use it once every eight months.
Barely pay like 50 bucks a month for it.
Never use it.
Well,
it's so much different though than the network because anybody can put their
shit up.
That's where it gets so weird.
It's like this is all so new and if it's,
we'll say youtube is our TV channels that you could watch through youtube
channel four channel.
Oh,
that's not what I'm talking about.
What I'm talking about is youtube originals.
Okay.
There youtube creating homes.
Yeah.
Those are different things.
But um,
it's just
what percentage of the views,
what percentage of the eyeballs of America does youtube have all of them?
Is it a hot,
I mean,
are you kidding?
How,
okay,
let's just go with the low number.
Giant.
What does the would,
the low number is how many people every day?
Don't watch youtube.
I watch youtube several times a day.
But what's the percentage of people,
if you had to guess that don't use youtube at all?
10 I would guess that maybe they probably have 90% of the people's eyeballs.
It's like the number it technically,
it's the number two search engine on the Internet as far as I've read too.
That hurts my bigger thing and all that.
Like it's,
it hurts my brain when you stop and think about how many fucking people must be
watching youtube videos around the world.
And it's just a company,
but it's like,
so then the,
then they're,
they're,
they're a network sort of,
but you are,
you're allowed to just have terms and conditions.
So you're allowed to upload and then they have to monitor your shit and make
sure you're not putting anything horrible up.
No.
Isis beheading something crazy.
You're like,
what numbers are you talking about?
How even looking at all this stuff,
one of the funniest videos on genre videos on youtube are Japanese.
They're supposed to be,
uh,
instructionals on Japanese massage.
It's like supposed to be an instructional.
This is,
it's all about instructional,
but it's not,
they take it as far as you can go for youtube.
Oh,
you can't go with becomes a porn almost while most companies you'll show
titties.
No educationally.
But no,
but they do.
You could find loudest showed titties and then there's laid out the nipple's.
Now there's youtube or naked chicks just just tie.
Go to youtube.
Naked chicks.
Boom.
Yeah,
he's talked about this before.
Here's my question.
Imagine if they had porn.
If they got right to the part where the people bone,
like why to the par and then they just gave you like outlines.
Like from then out,
all you see is like outlines of bodies moving.
You don't see any real dick or any real vagina.
BC outlines.
Yeah.
And dicks and vaginas feed up in the air and I bet that's all over youtube.
I wonder if they could do that.
You only got changed a couple of letters and you're on a real website that does
that for real.
Like like UJIs or your porn.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But I'm saying on youtube,
like what other terms and conditions is there.
Like could you get right to the port of people actually having sex and then just
all of a sudden just becomes not even an animation just becomes outlines.
You see people kissing loans,
they don't outline dicks.
Honestly don't have fake dicks and vaginas like tight shots.
You go tight shots of the chest,
back shoulder,
how fuck Blah in all,
all of it is just outlines.
Just a black screen with like white outlines of bodies on a bed.
Is the audio audio illegal?
That's a good question.
Yeah.
Is the audio,
is that illegal?
Is that okay?
What's the terms of conditions for you?
You can do a lot of stuff,
but I don't know at what point.
A couple of years ago they added,
I like age restriction,
right?
Sort of thing.
So you could probably do that but it'll get marked 18 and older only or
something.
Well,
here's the reason why I ask.
Twitter has porn,
straight up porn and I asked Jack Dorsey about it and he's like,
yeah,
we Twitter allows porn.
They allow porn.
Wow.
So you can be flipping through and someone's just got straight up.
Paul Coal Porn on the biggest mean it's gotta be,
if not the biggest social media platform on the planet earth.
It's top two,
right?
If it's not number one,
I'm never right.
I'm never on Twitter.
What is his number once Facebook,
Facebook's number one.
Are you on Twitter by just put things up there.
Read feeds,
occasionally read someone's feet if they got they post.
Interesting stuff.
I think snapchat's even harder,
but I avoided it for them.
I just don't have the time and I only have time for Instagram.
Snapchat as higher.
We'll either way it's closed.
Either way.
It's John,
it's giant.
I mean it's enormous and they allow porn,
which is kinda crazy cause like I know they're not as big as youtube in terms of
like total minutes watched of things.
And the thing is that most of what Twitter is his text,
most of it,
you know,
so when they have porn it's not,
it's like a fraction of what the whole thing is.
Whereas if youtube had porn,
it would very quickly become most of youtube.
Like if youtube just had porn,
people would blow a fucking gasket.
Cause kids are on youtube all the time.
Did you start and get on Youtube and looking things?
Somebody who's,
I'll show him but he's not.
Yeah,
he's like,
he's too young to get on the Internet.
They look at little kids stuff.
There's a lot of little kid content and that was one of the ways that people
were getting kids to watch so they can make ad revenue,
see those weird fucking videos they would find.
So like kids would be watching like Wiley,
coyote cartoons.
So they watched some Mickey mouse type cartoons and then all of a sudden it
would be like these cartoons,
superheroes that were babies and they were getting drunk and they would fall and
cut their head open.
It was like,
what the fuck is this?
And there was like,
ah,
hundreds of 'em and they had made it like with a formula just so that they could
catch kids in these algorithms that recommend the next video and play the next
video.
So it eventually get to their video because it would say,
you know,
like someone from frozen with Spiderman,
like and have those names in the title Elsa,
Elsa from frozen and Spiderman.
That's like there's a large,
something happened that we don't want that we missed.
I've heard about this recently too.
That's why I was actually pulling it up.
This is a really large youtube channel in there.
There's some sort of like inside joke going on to look at the Spiderman 10
million,
870,872 views.
What the fuck?
That's so many views.
If listen,
if a television show on CBS got that,
they'd be doing fucking backflips.
It'd be like,
look at all the views we got.
This is amazing.
This is Spiderman and Elsa.
Yeah.
I don't know.
There's just something else up.
But yeah,
so it's not like a dad to do that with a title,
a trademark spider putting the Spiderman,
find all of them.
They can't find all of them.
They try.
They,
I think they take some of them down AI that does that.
I think so.
Yeah,
sure.
Spiderman,
Spiderman.
But I think they're getting away with that because they were in a costume.
I think maybe you could get away with wearing a costume.
I don't know where those laws change fits.
How many much of parodies or spider man is like at this point.
Public domain,
the name or something.
No Way.
Cause then other people would be banging out Spiderman movies.
You imagine that if someone didn't own Spiderman of anybody can make their own
Spiderman movie.
Spiderman was just like an archetype hero.
But you know what?
Maybe there's some,
cause you can put out a video,
like if you wanted to talk some shit on Burt Reynolds or whatever,
you could put Burt Reynolds and they can't,
that's illegal.
Right?
Just putting people's names on the title.
Right.
But you,
but that's not what that is.
That's like they're making a video using copywritten characters that someone
created like Elsa from frozen and Spiderman for sure.
I feel like they probably got away with it because they were dressed up as them
rather than like drawing them.
Like if they had footage from the movie or animation,
they probably all have that shit copywritten.
Yeah.
But you could probably get away with,
if you have your own script and you make some stupid play with Elsen Spiderman,
you'd probably get away with that.
I don't know though,
man.
It's,
it's weird.
They're all like trying to figure out what you can and can't do.
You know,
what,
what can you not?
And so these companies that are making these weird fuck and that,
that was a,
a people one where there's people,
most of them that I saw,
they,
they purge them more animated.
They're a weird animations where it was always a baby and the baby would fall
and cut their head.
It was fucked up.
Like the same image would happen over and over again.
And there's these websites that are analyzing it and they were like,
what the fuck is this?
Like,
why is this baby fall?
And cut his head?
And like all these different versions of this same sort of story with different
characters.
It was just like,
uh,
like,
they had a pattern that they could stick it into.
So whatever the character was,
was Mickey Mouse or Donald Duck or they're always drinking.
And they fall and hit their fucking hat.
It's weird,
weird shit,
but they would get millions and millions and millions of views.
So someone was raking in the dough from advertising revenue from that.
I had a friend who dated a girl that ended up coming from a family of this.
Whoa.
Yeah,
broke up at there.
It's a long story,
but it's a very interesting story that I want to do.
They have a direct line to Satan know they broke up.
They were together for a couple of years and shit came out.
She's like,
multi-personality Satan,
his family father,
all that shit.
And then they broke.
He broke up with her naturally and,
but they kind of kept in contact and the last he heard that she got a job
programming children's TV at a large company.
You anyone to say the company
is a pretty good friend of mine.
He's,
he's not bullshitting,
but that's scary.
Did you see that preacher the got confronted by inside edition?
What does,
his name's Copeland.
Kenneth Copeland Brow.
It's whole Arius.
I don't know how much we,
we can show this because this will absolutely get us pulled.
Um,
this dude got confronted by inside edition.
They're doing these stories on these preachers that use the donations from their
flock to buy private jets and live like a bar.
And so she asks,
um,
you know,
is it true that you said that you don't want to fly commercial because you don't
want to be stuck in a tube with demons and he,
first of all,
he got caught off guard and he kind of was chilled at first,
but then he got mad at her when she asked that same question again.
He said,
no,
we're not,
didn't and don't you bring it up and don't you say I did.
That's what he says.
And he points at her and this push,
pull it ahead a little bit because,
uh,
this is the full version of this.
Pull it,
there's a that right before that,
right before that,
right before that.
Like she asks him,
what is he an evangelist?
Yeah.
He was a big tech.
Now we can't because we'll get pulled off of youtube for sure.
But he gets really fucking mad at her.
She said,
but didn't you say,
didn't you say that you can't fly commercial because the tube is filled with
demons?
Do you think that people are demons?
Like this lady has balls of steel cause this guy's giving her the crazy eyes and
he's saying all kinds of crazy shit to certain questions.
She also asked about like why did,
why did you buy it?
And he's like,
could be cause he made it so cheap.
Yeah,
it's like $980 million.
He made it so cheap.
It's like I couldn't say no.
That's what he says.
Ty was best guy made it so cheap.
That's it.
We're seeing it right there.
I had to buy it.
Yeah,
you can't.
Can't play it unfortunately,
but play it right after that.
Now this is where she asks him again.
He's getting frustrated with her.
This is where she asked him again about demons.
Now watch him get mad here.
Hold up.
But you can't play it because if you get paid,
if they fucking hear it,
they hear it.
They'll yank us.
Don't talk to Joe.
Joe Do what?
Jamie [inaudible] doesn't matter man.
It's whoever owns this content don't play any of the audio.
So he gets mad at her and she,
she's about to say it.
She's going to go,
but I'm sorry but didn't you say,
but didn't you say right before?
Yep.
Right there.
So watch this.
She goes,
don't you say that they were demons?
No,
look at this.
Don't you say that?
I did.
Look at that.
Look at that Bro.
That's intense.
And then he tries to charmer and he tries this trauma.
That to me is what I would imagine a demon would look like if you cornered it,
like be realistically.
Tell me back up,
back up right there.
There's a little bit before that but a little bit before it will.
He's actually angry a little bit before that.
Watch when he gets actually angry.
Like if if you taught the demons were real,
what would you think that they would behave like?
Wow.
They would just pretend to be people be all slippery.
What's happening here?
I just frozen backups so we could see them do it though.
Back up so we can see them do it.
See right here,
she asked him to watch this.
Watch this.
No,
don't say that.
I did.
And then watch this smile,
smile.
Just let it play.
Stop fucking around.
Watch this.
Look at that face.
Oh,
your friend again.
I'm just an ass preacher.
His hand looks like that.
Hobbit folk who looking at early,
his nails are long as fuck.
Just like say.
I would imagine Satan's none of a manicure,
Eddie.
He thought,
no,
it's,
you've got to look and evil and God,
that dude caught a sweet loophole.
Tax exempt status.
That's what's really interesting about churches.
Tax exempt baby.
They're doing the government's work.
The government's like,
you're doing such a good job of keeping these people in line.
Here you go.
Free,
free.
No taxes,
bro.
You're good.
Like imagine the government looking at televangelists going,
well seems legit.
Your definitely of the Lord's a words in mind and I definitely not making a ton
of money in the loophole,
so yeah.
Yeah,
for sure.
Keep that tax exempt status.
Seems good.
Seems super solid.
Imagine.
Imagine that like somewhere someone must have had that conversation,
whether or not they should have tax exempt status.
Like at what point in time,
you know,
like how about the Catholic Church?
How many sex scandals,
how many pedophiles scandals does it take before you lose tax exempt status?
Is there like a million?
How many cases?
How many cases do you need?
I get what point in time do you go,
maybe you
guys should fucking at least pay taxes.
You know,
maybe that's the deal.
They cut.
You don't go to jail for the kids,
but you got to start paying taxes.
Wow.
They're not prosecuting him because people aren't screaming for it.
What's really interesting is that if you look at some of the things that people
are really rallying about today,
what you would call it,
social justice warriors,
people are rallying around so many different causes.
Those,
those people that are rallying around all these causes,
supporting and Tivo doing this,
you know,
protecting this and going after that.
Well they're not doing is going after that church.
How come they're not shouting from the,
if you really want justice,
if you really want to do good in the world,
when you want to stop the pedophiles,
when you want to stop that,
if you didn't,
you don't see that.
It's too scary for people so big.
They've got their own country,
the Vatican's basically a country.
They got their own passport.
Yeah,
it's dark.
It's dark.
When people look like they,
they feel like they're doing progress and then do you not stop in that?
You're not.
You're not like your concern is what?
What's your concern?
The sculpture of the resurrection.
Have you seen that?
No.
Evil.
What is the Vatican?
It's supposedly,
it's supposed to be Jesus rising from the dead,
but it looks like a Zombie.
It looks,
it looks like hell,
and that's that.
Yeah.
The sculpture of the resurrection.
There's some,
and then they got syrup.
They got a serpent,
a cathedral where it looks like a serpent's head.
It's crazy stuff.
You been,
no,
but I've seen it on youtube.
You've been an idiot.
It'll yet.
No,
you should go.
Dude is insane.
It's so insane.
The Vatican.
So insane.
It's absolutely worth it.
You went up,
you went into the Vatican.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
The artwork is off the charts.
You can't believe it.
St Peter's Basilica.
That's it right there.
Who fucking made that?
That's supposed to be something about like,
Bro,
that looks at represents Christianity Gate in front of Marilyn Manson's house.
Yeah,
totally.
Dude.
Marilyn Manson would be rocking.
This is they're depleted puppy POW.
The PNF of e.
Dot.
Yeah,
make a great photo shoot would be an amazing gate.
Right?
If you would like to.
Ultimate horror fiction writer.
Like Stephen King bought a house in the Hollywood hills.
Yeah,
and that was his gate.
Look up on the service erection feed.
Does that put the serpent cathedral?
Vatican.
That's,
that's crazy dude.
It's looks like a snake.
So there's a,
there's a thing in there called St Peter's Basilica,
man.
You Ne,
you'd never seen anything like that in your life.
Right there.
Look at that.
Wow.
It looks like.
Come on man.
That's correct.
That's crazy.
It has the eyes of a snake,
the head of a snake and the fangs that is very,
you can see that resurrection thing right there.
Oh my God.
Oh,
come on,
God.
That's amazing.
That's amazing dude.
If you were dating a girl into a Jesus right there,
dude,
I don't see Jesus anywhere.
If you were dating a girl and she's really into witchcraft,
he'd want to fuck her.
Right?
Right in between the teeth.
Maybe I want to take you to the Vatican where sneak away.
I'm going to bribe somebody.
I'm gonna fuck you between the teeth.
Yeah,
that's scary.
Imagine if they just had a bed that you could borrow.
What if the pope is really the king of the world?
I got them out there.
It was crazy.
So it's definitely not.
Yes,
he might be.
It might be the most powerful man.
So let me ask you this.
What do you think about all this alien shit that's going on right now?
All this Ufo Shit.
What do you think that is?
You think that's a distraction?
The stuff that's going on right now,
100% the size.
It just got d class.
They're trying.
That's what it is.
Uh,
the thighs,
the d class,
are you kidding?
That's going to bury a lot.
Lot of people going to jail.
So you think that's why the Ufo stuff is out there?
It's always been about Ufo.
It's really since that they do that,
like they have certain Ufo cases that they say,
listen,
if anything gets weird,
we're just going to let this motherfucker lose.
Woo.
And we're going to tell people,
listen,
we've seen the aliens,
we've got a hold of them.
We've got an alert congress,
we've got to talk to people.
And then people start just forgetting about corruption,
forgetting about the BP oil spill.
Forget about whatever the fuck is.
Dude,
the aliens are coming.
Trust me.
Yes,
they've been talking to the government.
You know what my argument against it has always been?
Why would they talk to the government if you're from another fucking planet?
Like we,
when we visit chimpanzees,
we don't say,
Hey,
who's the number one champ?
We want to bring you bananas and signed a peace treaty with you.
We don't give a fuck who the leader is.
Get out of here.
You don't get special deals.
Alisha,
oh,
the top champ made a deal to let us kidnap some baby chimps so he could bring
them to the zoo.
Yeah.
The fuck out of here.
If they're coming here from another planet,
they must be so much more sophisticated than we are.
They're not gonna listen to us.
We're crazy.
They're doing it for several reasons in my opinion.
And one like exactly like you said,
when there's fewer distractions and right now they're going heavy with it.
But you know,
Warner von Braun,
uh,
the last four years of his life,
he had cancer and he had an assistant and you can watch it on youtube talking.
Her name is doctor Carol Rosalynn.
And she said that he kept telling her over and over because they're preparing
like on his deathbed,
that preparing for a fake alien invasion.
Oh,
that's what they're doing.
They're trying to scare us into a new world order downtime.
And she talked about no,
no,
she,
she doesn't say why.
He goes,
he never told me why.
He just kept telling me they're all this stuff you hear about aliens and
asteroids.
It's all fake.
First there's going to be,
uh,
an environmental threat that they're going to scare everybody up with global
warming is my opinion,
in my opinion.
Then there's going to be an asteroid threats and then the final one,
and she says this,
and he kept saying that.
She goes to the final one.
The last one they're going to do is the fake alien
invasion that's going to,
that's why there's movies like Independence Day.
It gets everyone used to,
uh,
we're all gonna,
Ugh,
let's call China and Russia and we all band together.
It's,
it's to get us prepared for a new,
a one world government.
That's what it's really all about.
The aliens and all that.
The Nazis were doing that to their own people.
They may in the,
when I was balls deep in the Ufo community,
we would,
they would,
they would show us that,
you know,
there's pictures of the German Ufos and in the Ufo community we looked at that
as evidence that they must've found crashed you,
fos.
And then they're trying to reverse engineer them.
That's what everybody in the Ufo community thinks.
But when you look into it do,
they were trying to scare their own people to look for the government.
They're,
they're just scaring us so that we go to the governor's science fiction had
flying saucers before flying saucers where something that the government or the
journal,
you look at the time and none of the time here go,
tried to create.
So I think they were try,
if they were trying to freak people out and just make it seem like it was
allergies.
Yes.
Yeah,
exactly.
So,
so we'll,
war is over with operation paperclip,
operation paperclip,
1945 1946 we bring in over all the guys that ended up creating the CIA and NASA
were from operation paperclip.
So right away short NASA.
So when you look at this,
if the Nazis were trying to scare their own people with fake foes,
they must've came in and said,
dude,
you guys aren't on the Ufo Shit.
You got to scare your people.
So that's exactly when all the comic books were all these comic books.
So the Germans were scaring their people with Ufos before the United States gets
guys with CFOs.
Really?
Yes.
This was the 30s that is,
listen,
if you're going to be a master of a propaganda like Hitler was,
right?
Yes,
manipulation and propaganda.
That would be the movement.
Who want him to new world order more than Hitler who wanted to control the world
more than that guy.
That guy knew how to do it and it's an old idea.
It's an old idea or way.
Everybody,
the old,
the ancient Roman emperors,
they all want,
they all dreamt for that one world government.
They couldn't pull it off.
There was no way they could pull it off cause you,
the only way to make a new world order actually happen is you've got to get the
people to embrace it.
You can't force him into it,
so you got a mind fuck them to embrace a new world order.
You've got to make them want it,
otherwise they're not going to stay in their own little tribe.
Exactly.
Yeah.
You know the little problem on the little rulers would go like,
dude,
we do a one world government.
I'm a out of a job.
Fuck you.
It's impossible.
But they knew.
They theorized if there was some kind of alien threat,
they don't.
You remember Reagan talking about exactly one year in the Ufo community,
you take that Reagan speech from the UN and from the CFR and you look at that as
proof that there's aliens,
but now I look at that.
When you look at him and I get the CFR,
he goes,
wouldn't all our jobs be a little bit easier if there was some sort of threat,
some extra terrestrial threat?
He's,
Tom says the rule.
Well,
it's not exactly what he said.
No,
no,
no.
You're talking about the UN one.
I'm talking about a different one.
He did it many,
two different too.
He was doing it all.
A bunch of them.
Yeah,
he was on a mission to get everyone and putting it to sound like,
but he's like making it sound like humanitarian,
like wooden.
What we,
all our differences just seem to diminish.
If there was some sort of extra trust,
you'll thrive.
That was getting,
everybody used to this shit,
we're going to come.
The UN is all about a one world got off.
They can't.
They can't do it,
but now we're approaching the tech.
We have the technology now with holograms now we could do it.
It's always been for hundreds of years.
They knew that.
They knew that,
but they couldn't pull it off.
How are you going to pull it up?
How are you going to do to know how to make that shit or making movies when you
imagine,
what are you saying?
I told you about this last week.
You said you didn't see it.
What it is.
I'm just talking about the military industrial component.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
Oh,
let me hear that.
Let me hear that.
Yeah.
Was that free use this.
You're talking about spreads force the president.
Is he talking about space for it?
No.
You can reassure people you're not looking for them.
This is Fox News,
man.
You can't play this news yet.
It's Fox.
It's like a clip from it.
Fox News.
It's the news though.
Yeah,
but I think you get pulled for,
if you don't want me to play it on one,
play it,
but you can always play.
Then let me know.
Let me hear him say,
this is my friend Steve Hill.
Michelle there,
and don't kid yourself.
You do have a military industrial complex.
They do like war,
you know in Syria with the caliphate,
so wipe out 100% of the caliphate.
That doesn't mean you're not going to have these crazy people going around
blowing up stores and blowing up things.
He's a seriously ill people.
I don't want to say,
oh,
they're wiped out.
You know Isis,
but I wiped out 100% of the caliphate.
I should.
I want to bring our trips back home.
The place went crazy.
They want to keep that.
You have people here in Washington on it.
They never want to leave.
I said,
you know what I'll do?
I'll leave a couple of hundred soldiers behind,
but if it was up to them,
they'd bring thousands of soldiers in someday.
People will explain it.
[inaudible] have,
Whoa,
yeah,
that's fucking heavy.
I'll stop right here.
Now,
if that was from anyone in any normal person,
you would say,
that guy's out of his fucking mind.
That's a conspiracy.
There's no one who wants war.
But you hear that from the actual sitting president of the United States who has
no reason to say that.
Like,
why is he,
why does he have a reason to say that?
It must be an excuse for why he didn't pull everyone out.
100% and that's an,
that's a really overlooked insight.
And that's part of the problem is that so many people hate Trump.
But even when he says something like that,
that we should listen to because it's coming from the president of the United
States while he's a sitting president and why he's talking about pulling people
out of true at a war.
And people still don't want to listen because it's on Fox News and because it's
the president,
because people,
so many people hate the president.
They don't want to hear about this.
That should be something that's talked about.
The,
the d class is about to happen.
Shit.
There you think so?
Well,
what does the d class that's about to happen?
It's,
you know,
what does that mean?
You mean Dee d classification?
Pfizer applications at declasse.
Everything involved in how the Russian
started.
That's the problem.
They were,
there's evidence.
This is coming with the Pfizer class that Trump won,
supposed to win.
There's text messages going back between,
uh,
two FBI agents saying,
well,
what if he wins and goes,
he ain't going nowhere.
And he's got,
Hillary's is going to crush them like a zillion to one and is,
but what if he does win?
And these are text messages had been released up.
Anybody can do that.
He got hit.
So bad folks were back from Pittsburgh.
We had to go.
I've been drinking a lot of water lately.
I'm trying to be super healthy.
Need soon,
man.
I thought Pellegrino was good enough.
I thought
there's no way those bubbles are good for you.
You know what I mean?
Look,
yeah,
let's find out.
No dentists saying fuck it.
What would happen?
What would happen to your body?
How if all you drank was,
was Perrier and Pellegrino and that's it.
No,
forget about the teeth.
The overall health of the body.
So much about the by,
it's by your teeth is what that is.
No,
but forget about the tea,
but it's going to give you a chance when you get,
but the carbonation has got gotta be doing something to you.
Teeth is all it's really doing.
I wonder if it's doing something to your orders to or something to your teeth
because of the carbonation.
It's got to,
it's got to be,
it's just water and carbonation.
So where's the carbonation is in nitrogen in the water.
Like what's,
what is the carbonation?
It's nitrogen,
man.
I hope it's great for you.
I hope I hose acid acids,
higher acidity.
Oh my God.
It's bad for you can be good.
Right.
And that's all I was drinking for awhile,
but I was happy with myself because,
you know,
I feel like you do.
I'm good.
My vice was coca cola,
so it got me off coke.
I don't give a fuck about coke and got off it.
I'll drink coke every now and then,
but I'm not,
I used to be like,
I want it like with a meal.
If I went out to a restaurant,
had to have a fucking coke,
but now Pellogrino is,
it's totally satisfies me.
I'm good,
I'm good with it.
But then I just got away with,
I just kept drinking just that.
Anything,
it's better than coke,
but it's not as good as water.
I'm going to go with that.
Yeah,
it's gotten way better than coke.
Coke is the worst,
but why is it so delicious?
Dude?
Some some food.
You just want a cold diet coke with.
Look,
if I have a fucking cheeseburger,
I know I'm already not eating healthy fucking diet coke.
Why are we playing games?
Right?
You know,
that failing is that a Pellegrino is good enough for me is good enough with your
burger,
it's satisfying.
But if you're going to have a burger and fries best as Coca Cola,
for sure.
God Damn Coke,
you'll work it off in the gym.
Fucked diet.
Not Diet like regular coke.
Regular kind of like regular coke.
It's too syrupy.
It's just too hard for me.
It's just Jamie's like,
oh,
I miss it because Jamie's Midwest,
Midwest,
they give it to their babies.
They put it in bottles and shit.
Put Cop can bottle or a [inaudible] code of breast bottle was asking coke.
Then she'd pull it in a bottle.
Yeah.
Oh I bet you you'd like to stay the styrofoam
only polo has got a weird flavor coke that I really liked that got me back into
drinking it a long time ago.
Chipolte lay has their own Allen.
People say Mcdonald's.
Coke is the best.
I highly disagree.
No,
it's definitely not.
It's weird.
Yet they have different flavors.
They send the traces like different now announces its original taste on the
label at Chipola,
which is
weird like which you make a deal with coke and you don't know which flavor
you're getting.
Let me ask you this.
Do you think Andy or wheeze being the heavyweight champion of bring Mexicans and
the rest of America closer together?
I think so.
What if he starts fucking everybody up?
What if he fucks up everybody?
What if he becomes the man?
That would be amazing.
Vivaan may go,
oh man.
Crazy interesting.
Right?
Like what Joe Lewis was or what Muhammad Ali was during the civil rights
movement.
How about that?
What's his record?
Has He ever lived?
He's taking his 31 on one,
one loss,
but it was a split decision to Joseph Parker who's a legit worldclass fighter.
Hmm.
Um,
so one decision point 29.
Yeah,
he's young,
young guy and he's fucking good man.
Like he's good.
People get confused because of the way he looks.
That motherfucker throws hands and the way he punches it's super fluid.
Everything is like blah,
blah blah blah,
blah,
like nasty combinations like way quicker than most heavyweights.
Wait,
wait quicker.
Really interesting man.
When you watch him fight like wow.
So the fights,
the fight is him versus that bronze bomber guy.
Right.
Well,
I would imagine the fight is the rematch in England and the fucking Wembley
arena or some shit in front of a million people.
That's probably got to be the rematch.
And if he fucks him,
I bug him wedge shot,
man.
I don't know what happened in that fight.
Um,
but if I Tyson fury too,
right?
Oh yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
He could fight Tyson fury.
I mean,
Andy can fight Tyson fury and can fight,
uh,
Deontay wilder.
But the big money I think is in the rematch.
That's probably where the big money is.
And then that's the problem with dad has man,
all of the sudden that heavyweight division looks good.
It's cool.
It's great right now.
This is as good as the heavyweight division has been in decades.
It's amazing right now.
But the most exciting is Deontae cause Deontae flatlines people with one shot
and this crazy way and he's just built like a,
he's built like a giant Tommy Hearns almost like,
you know,
when he just,
he just got crazy power man.
His power makes me just put my hand on my hand and go,
what the fuck?
Like Francis and Gattica box.
I know he could box at the top left at the top level.
No,
I mean I think he could with training,
but he's a little older too.
You know Francis.
Hello?
How old is Francis?
I want to say he's 34 he started fairly late in life.
Learning how to fight in period.
But uh,
he's so big and so powerful,
man.
What is he?
30 to 32 is not bad.
That's young.
That's pretty young.
He's,
he in my opinion,
is the most dangerous one punch guy I've ever seen.
He,
he,
if you make any mistake with that guy,
it's slow heavyweights.
Just go flying across the room.
If you think of Francis and Ghana versus Andy Ruiz would be big.
Andy Ruiz is a way better boxer.
So he's a way,
way,
way better boxer.
It's a big difference.
[inaudible] hundred amateur fights.
People would see it just like people wanna to see Floyd Mayweather versus Conor
McGregor.
Yeah.
But it's kind of the same in the same way that you know,
you know,
Conor McGregor knocks people dead in the UFC and you know,
Floyd Mayweather's the greatest boxer of all time,
of all time.
I mean he's probably the most skillful defensive artists we've ever seen and
flow.
You know,
Floyd got hit a couple of times.
The thing about Francis and Gannon was I think even with big gloves,
you can't let him hit you like that.
If he gets,
if it like a Floyd.
The way Floyd got hit with that upper cut by Connor Connor just kind of placed
it there.
He popped him.
It was a good shot.
But Floyd didn't get wobbled.
He didn't get dropped.
If Francis,
it's somebody like that,
I don't give a fuck who you are.
If he hits you with that Alistair Overeem left hook that he hit,
asked her with get the fuck outta here.
No one surviving that.
He just seems like the way he knocked out cane,
we clipped him with that little short upper cut and cane seemed like it.
Didn't even know your hit.
Yeah,
I think he hits stupid hard,
like crazy ridiculous off the charts hard.
I think when it hits people,
they're just like,
what in the hell?
The only guy who's been able to survive that shit is Steve Bay and of course
Derek Lewis,
but they just didn't do much to each other in that fight.
Everybody else,
he touches you with that Shit and you just go flying.
He had so god damn hard that if he just went into boxing straight instead of
UFC,
who the fuck knows man?
He could be the fucking heavyweight champion of the world.
Like legitimately.
If you stop and think about how quickly Deontay wilder went from boxing to
earning a bronze medal in the Olympics,
it was a year and a half.
I mean while there is exceptionally talented,
exceptionally powerful,
unbelievable one punch,
knockout power,
but so's Francis like a Francis has chosen to go that path.
Who fucking knows?
Man?
Who knows if he learns how to wrestle,
like really learns how to wrestle and really learned how to submit.
People can imagine like where everybody has to stand with them because you're
scared of him.
On the ground.
Yeah.
I mean,
he's at 265 pounds natural and shredded the way he is with unbelievable power.
That's just a super unusual case.
Like I could have any,
any combat sport.
If you went into kickboxing,
same shit.
Be fucking everybody up just hit.
So God damn hard.
He hits people and you just go Young's like,
whoa.
It's hard to learn
Jujitsu once you're already famous.
That's a tough one.
That is draw the top.
It's tough because the only way to learn Jujitsu correctly is with a hundred
percent.
It's boring.
And you don't do that with your wrestling would wrestling by you.
You can go hundred percent supporting with dressing because there's no,
you don't do that.
What you striking.
Yeah.
You don't do that with your striking,
not that much.
Yeah.
But um,
it's positive.
Once you become famous,
it very hard to go 100% with just anybody.
You know what I mean?
It's others.
Um,
a lot on the line.
Yeah.
It's possible,
but it would have to be well engineered by a really good manager,
right?
Yeah.
Like someone like a Dan Lambert and comes along and says,
this is how we're going to do this.
We're going to take this as a project and we're going to bring in wrestlers and
these guys are going to specifically work with you on these very specific drills
are going to help you get up and help you stay up.
And we're gonna,
we're gonna.
This is what are our job is our job as now this and we're going to turn you into
the heavyweight champion of the world.
But it would have to be like someone who had like a real specific group of guys
that knew the goal and that there was no egos involved.
So it wasn't,
you're not going to bring in some guys going to try to out wrestle him or hurt
him or knock him out or do anything.
They,
they,
they're,
they're working for the goal,
but that's hard to do.
You know,
everybody has their own ideas.
that's one of the real problems that a fighters have at a really high levels.
Finding people that you can train with that are commensurate and skill level,
but they're not trying to take you out,
you know,
to aid each other.
Like imagine,
imagine if Mark Kerr got balls deep into Jujitsu and got class.
He would've been,
he would've had a longer career,
that's for sure.
And you know,
if he got good on the back,
oh my God.
See that with wrestlers every now and then,
like after six,
seven years.
Do you see it like,
oh my God,
they're taking the back down there,
choking people out.
You saw that with John Fitch.
You know,
it took a while.
He,
he was just cool with ground and pound and just getting the take down and then
slowly start.
He started seeing him pass and,
and take backs and then he took sacks.
Anthony Smith choking out customers.
Crazy.
Is that yes,
he did it with a broken hand.
Yeah.
Yeah man,
that was,
that was pretty crazy.
Fucking dude is the real deal.
Yeah,
he's the real deal.
How did the Jon Jones fight go?
I don't remember.
John Jones is how class he was ahead of him.
He knew what he was going to do before decision.
Yeah,
five rounds.
Five round decision.
Okay.
Dominant decision.
John,
just a,
I mean,
he looked at her wobbled or knocked down.
Now you've got hit.
I mean you definitely got hit.
He got,
he took some shots,
but he was fine at the end of it.
Um,
early in the fight though he show he looked very smooth,
very fluid and the first round he looked very good,
very,
very composed considering world title,
fight against Jon Jones.
I mean,
everything he did when he was moving,
he wasn't exploding.
It wasn't blowing away any nervous energy fought very technically very good
technical stand up and just look.
John is just John John's on another level.
There's everybody else.
Then there's John Jones.
It's another level.
He knows when you're tired too.
He,
he,
you see him when he senses like any,
any time where you're trying to catch a break,
he senses
it and he starts ramping it up and moving towards you and kicking your legs.
So you see it smells blood.
He smells blood.
He's a fucking straight up killer man.
He just knows there's a lot of aspects to his game that are very interesting,
but he just knows how to feel where a guy is.
He knows the distance in terms of like knowing how to feel where a guy is in
terms of how far away the guy is from him.
Cause he's the best ever at utilizing as long reach.
But he also knows where the guy is psychologically.
He know.
He knows when guys are physically tired,
knows who's he fighting next?
He's going to fight Tiago Santos.
I don't know too much about it.
I'm like,
God that guy throws ex more of a striker.
Oh yeah.
Way More.
More.
He's got a giant hammer tattooed on his chest,
knocks people in another dimension.
He's a beast,
man.
It'll legit beast.
Which is that,
um,
that's a,
it's not,
August is not August in La.
I think that's a,
the Anti Sim card I think.
Am I making that up?
That's great.
Fucking fight though.
Great fight for as long as it lasts.
Who knows?
You know that guy,
he can knock anybody out.
It's just swings wild.
But you,
John should be a heavy favorite going into the fight.
John Fights on the July card.
Oh,
it is the July card.
Oh my God,
that's right.
That's right.
That's where I got confused.
Anaheim steepen and DC.
John Jones versus Taco Santos one.
Oh,
that was on steep NDCs is on.
Yes.
I don't remember.
I Want Paula Costa is also re booked for that.
That's Anaheim as well,
right?
Yeah.
Whoo.
Yoel Romero.
Paula Costa,
best body ever fight.
They're fighting for the best body ever.
That's what they're doing.
Like who's the king?
[inaudible] boss.
Yes.
Well,
you'll might never fight again.
He won $27 million I gave up because there was a supplement company that had
tainted supplements.
Legitimately,
they tested them independently and they found out that this shit is,
it's tainted and it makes people piss hot for steroid tests.
Hm.
So he sued them.
The question is whether or not he's going to be able to correct,
uh,
collect rather because,
um,
you know,
when you sue someone,
they can go bankrupt.
Like if they're a corporation,
that's why someone forms an LLC.
So if they've got some steroid tainted shit and athlete Susan,
I wonder if they actually have to pay or if one that they could just disband the
company cause 27 million is a lot of money.
You know?
Who knows?
The company might not have been worth 27 million.
I don't know what the company is.
Do you know what the company is right now?
What's the name of it?
Gold.
Gold Star performance.
That's a big name.
I've heard that name before.
Have you heard that name before?
I think that's a big name and supplements.
You know what,
man,
if anything,
it'll blow them up.
It'll be worth it.
Just Pam,
we're going to make 100 million because a people are going to jump on it.
You know what I mean?
Like people got professionally.
Oh Shit.
Cool.
Let's do it.
Yeah,
that's true.
Right?
Give me the shit that Hector Lombard pissed dot for 100% that shit.
I got that shit on.
You're going to get a thick old neck.
Cool.
What's up Jamie?
They got,
what if this is the right company?
I just looked up when I tried to type it in the revenue.
They're doing all right.
Yeah.
How much they worth,
I don't know if this is the right company,
but the one I just found says they did.
I got a cash balance of 96.5 million as of December 31st 27 million to the Cuban
bay.
Be Not be the actual same company,
but it's got the same name.
At least a business.
That company,
let's say it is that comedy.
Come on,
give up that money.
I want to see Yoel Romero just covered in furs.
Gold chains and shit.
Just live in like a pimp.
Well,
I want to see Yoel Romero and like,
uh,
some sort of crazy gazelle skin coat with like full six pack.
Just know minks right.
Makes it be better.
Like some,
something crazy.
Just 27 million in the bank,
not giving a fuck.
20 girls around.
He'll start rapping and Cuban.
It's pretty good.
I'm fucking guy.
He's the freakiest athlete I've ever seen.
He moves so fast.
Sometimes.
You like,
like what?
Like he,
you know,
when he fought Chris Weidman,
I remember when he landed that flying knee,
I was like,
oh my God,
that guy can do that.
Out of nowhere,
out of nowhere,
you,
you can never sleep on him because he'll,
he like lulls you into this false sense of everything being okay.
He moves slow,
you know,
he just moves slow,
he moves slow and move away.
When you kick them loose,
it almost like he's conserving energy and I boom,
he just jumps on you.
It's amazing to see a guy like him at 40 years of age beat that fucking
explosive.
You know,
you're right at 40 with that lawsuit shit in my life fight.
He might go maybe once a fuckup Paulo Kosta and that's a wrap after that fight.
But if he actually gets the money,
that's the problem.
See it's all bullshit until the money's in your bank account.
Cause if they appeal and you know the dragon into appeals court,
which they probably will,
right,
man,
I'd imagine gears took years.
Yeah.
And then the meanwhile,
if they have that money,
they could just invest that money and just make itself back and then give them
what they invested with,
Eh,
yeah,
here's your money.
It didn't cost a shit.
I could do that too.
As long as it's long enough.
Maybe they have like 500 million.
They're like 25 million.
The whole supplement world is a weird world.
It's very weird.
You know?
We had problems with the on it with Alpha brain early.
We are a Alpha brain,
had other shit in it with different vitamins and that they weren't supposed to
be in there.
I'm like,
what is this and that.
It's,
we had to change suppliers.
It's tricky man.
When you're making stuff and you're not there for every step of the way,
you hire companies to do it and like,
well how are they doing it?
How are they mixing it?
What's the VAT look like?
Did they clean that shit?
You know,
and then somewhere down the Rhine,
like Tim means he was another one.
I remember Tim means tend to dirty bird is a bad motherfucker.
He same thing.
Pissed hot for some shit that was just some over the counter stuff.
They found it but they,
they gave him like six months.
I think they give you all a long time too though,
didn't they?
They give them like six months or something like that.
I don't know.
I think they gave him a long time.
It was like six months,
which apparently is where 27 million.
27,000 nice number two men.
You got a six month suspension?
Yeah,
whatever.
Be Perfect.
If he gets that 27 million he won't give a fuck about that.
Six months suspension.
If you had 27 million clean in the bank that you don't have to pay taxes on,
is that how it works?
No.
You got to pay taxes.
Do you when you get a lawsuit that seemed,
some of them are definitely thinking like why not?
It seems it seems ridiculous.
Why would the government,
you could keep that.
Why would the government get a piece of you getting your little career?
Devry?
I know,
but isn't that nuts?
They get a,
but that's funny.
Like they ruled that you got damaged.
So someone has to give you money to make up for all the money that you lost.
You lost $27 million worth of revenue.
We're gonna make it right you well,
so they give them that $27 million in the government is like not so fast.
You might have lost 27 million,
but we didn't get our A's.
I bet you have to pay taxes.
If you didn't have to pay taxes on things.
Imagine how few people would pay taxes.
You know,
it would be like if the IRS wasn't so fucking ruthless chases people down,
it would be like those uh,
things.
We,
you bought 99 records for a dollar.
I remember that.
Or nobody ever paid for it.
The record club,
they,
David send you the cassette penny.
Yeah,
there was it like a petty and you'd get like used to pick these,
you get to pick this.
Oh,
Reo Speedwagon Oh,
Billy Joel,
the stranger and you get to check off the list and the bonus one ever pays.
No one paid.
I don't know,
a single person to pay.
They tried to chase me down.
Maybe they didn't want the money.
They just wanted to spread the music.
Maybe they did.
It was a scam.
Maybe they have insured themselves against a certain amount of loss in certain
amount of suckers paid cause they did harass you a little bit.
They'd send you letters like,
hey man sent you a all those kiss cassettes.
You haven't gotten back to us.
Remember that?
Did you do that Jamie Columbia House?
It's called Columbia records.
I will send you shit like a box.
Shit.
You didn't want him like,
I don't want Hala notes.
Was it Columbia House records or Columbia records house?
It was a club TV guides.
That's what always ask for insert two.
That's the first time I found out about,
well it was actually late night TV about dianetics.
I didn't know dianetics is Scientology.
I thought it was like a,
you know you got kick ass,
take on the world,
get away from your insecurities and your fears.
Drag you in a little bit first he dragged you in with a volcano and smart.
They're showing the volcano and the commercial.
That's way better than than like those dudes you see at the freeway overpasses
that are screaming.
Jesus says,
Jesus saves like,
Dude,
how can block you from doing this?
You ain't bringing nobody that Jesus man.
Yeah,
but it's smart.
You don't tell them you want to get someone in Jesus.
You don't tell them it's about Jesus.
You know what I mean?
Just pour in itself help.
The real way to get someone in who Jesus is to lead by Jesus's example and be a
really good Christian and someone says,
well why are you such a nice person?
Say because I'm a Christian and a real Christian is a really nice person and the
person and be like,
damn,
I want to be a really nice person.
And I said,
well why don't you come to church with me on Sunday and next thing you know you
go to church with them.
That's how you do.
It's how you do it.
You can't be screaming at Jesus on the corner of Hollywood boulevard and the
Bra,
but then when they corner you,
you're
don't.
You see that
you got pretty high.
That's going to be cut up.
Okay.
I see him demonic to me,
man.
He creeped me the fuck out.
That creeped me out man.
That guy's used to tell them people things like that.
Used to yell at people and point his finger out long fingernail Polish that you
don't,
you don't.
You see I did
it.
Make it great.
Imagine what it must be like to be a fly on the wall.
One of those billion dollar preachers just in must be getting pussy.
They must be,
oh it has to be right.
Of course has to be top shelf there.
But flying him in from Czechoslovakia and Shit,
just they got the crew of actors,
CNN on a fucking hill of cocaine.
It's crazy how,
yeah,
they got a bunch of actors and plants and all that shit.
But it's crazy how they get people to believe it and they get,
they get put in trances and shit and you know some of them over acting,
but some of them are like,
you know,
there's a certain percentage of people that are hypnotizable.
What is it?
What is it like,
you know what?
Maybe it's the people that didn't get sucked into pro wrestling.
Pro Wrestling could have gotten them.
They would have believed that that was real.
They missed that.
And they got,
they got sucked into like the snake handlers and shit.
Cause when you go to uh,
the,
you know those,
those hypnotist shows,
the scam is that before the show,
like this is considered the scam part is before the show.
They go into the audience and they find people that are easily hypnotized,
right?
So then they bring them out of things they do is they let you be aware that they
might call upon you.
And so just to make sure that your story matches,
we would like to know what ever happened to you.
Is there something that's bothering you so that we know that when the Cindy,
the magnificent,
when she calls out to you that your story matches up with a piece of paper,
this little weird tricks they do with people.
They ask them to fill out these forms,
talk about their childhood.
That's the psychic psychic shit for sure.
Like A,
that's how they're going.
Just like listening to people talk.
But I'm talking about preachers do.
That.
Hypnotist shows where they take like a couple,
maybe they take one person and they hypnotize them.
Then they wake him up on,
they make them do weird shit that they don't remember.
Oh yeah dude,
I saw that before.
I've seen it.
So that's real.
Oh real.
So there
are people,
a certain percentage of the population who knows what it is.
Maybe it's 10% maybe it's 60% who knows?
But there are people that can be put under a spell on under a spell in it.
They could be in a trance while they're awake.
They're awake and they do something under command with without any control and
they don't remember it.
And then they get snapped out of it all.
That's real.
Yes.
That's crazy.
So varying degrees,
but,
and it's real in live audiences,
which is particularly weird.
Yeah.
Frank Santos,
the r rated hypnotists was a staple in Boston when I was coming up and I was an
open,
Mike or Frank actually even ran a comedy club at one point in time and it's just
his son is a hypnotist now.
Frank Santos,
we,
he would do stitches,
comedy club,
me and Greg Fitzsimmons and Nick Depalo and all these guys.
We saw him do this and he would do it on a regular basis.
It happens every week.
You had one night a week and it wasn't just that club,
it was one night a week we get stitches,
but it was like one night a week at Nick's comedy stop and one night a week we'd
get giggles,
sorry.
Um,
but he would get a bunch of people out of the audience and he would have a bunch
of volunteers who wants to volunteer and you get the people on the stage and
everybody be like,
Whoa,
I can't believe we're here.
And they would hit and ties and hypnotize me,
hypnotize me and do this thing.
You're getting sleepy,
you're gonna listen to me.
I'm going to count to five and when I count to five,
you are going to be doing pushups and underneath you is going to be Madonna and
she's going to be naked.
And he would do that and it would work on some people and look at people who
was,
you're not under,
come on,
come with me.
And he would get rid of them.
But then some people would just be under and you'd be like,
this isn't real.
Is this real?
But then you would see your friend go up there.
You would see someone you knew go up there and you'd see people see their
friends go up there and what they couldn't believe it.
And the person was really doing it.
And you could tell they were really doing it and they'd be so embarrassed.
They'd be so embarrassed when they found out that they did this in front of
these people.
They were like,
what?
Yeah,
you came in your pants and like some guys would actually come in their pants,
they would come in their pants.
He would tell them,
I'm gonna count to three.
And I like number three.
You're going to come in your pants one,
two,
three and you got to be like,
oh.
He'd seem to get like super embarrassed.
Like,
these are good actors,
but you could see the embarrassment,
their face,
there would be wilderness.
There were so confused.
They were like,
what happened?
How did this happen?
But it wasn't everybody go on.
If there's probably couldn't go wonder if there's a,
I would love to see a documentary on people getting hypnotized and like proving
that it's real and doing different wines.
Hypnotized.
I got hypnotized.
They're real.
Yeah.
But I didn't get rid hypnotized to do anything.
I got hypnotized by Vinny shoreman.
Vinny shoreman,
the mental coach.
Did he make you do things you didn't remember?
Hope not.
No.
I just laid there.
I any gay.
He gave it to me.
No,
I laid there and uh,
he talked to me while I was laying there and one when he was talking to me,
I knew he was there and I knew I was there and I knew I was just chilling on
this couch.
It wasn't like I,
I was in a trance and I was going somewhere and I was very aware that it was
happening,
but it was,
he was put me,
he was putting me in a suggestive state.
And he was talking to me about various things that I wanted to work on.
Mostly Organization and discipline stuff like discipline,
like getting things done and we just want something that I'm always
concentrating on.
And uh,
then when it was over,
it was just over.
I was awake through all of it.
But it was weird.
It was like a weird state.
It was like as if like the regular world has like a crazy filter over it.
Like where you stone,
that's a yes.
It's hard to guess.
I would probably say yes.
It sounds like you were hypnotized.
Like the Kinda like those dudes that don't remember what they did and all that.
But he doesn't do that though.
And I think other people can do that and I think they do that to some people,
but that's not what he's trying to do.
Anybody his I think,
and I'm speaking for Vinny,
um,
but I think that anybody can allow themselves to get into this suggestive stayed
to get into this state of hypnosis,
but that's different than the kind of people that will think that they really
are having sex with Madonna on stage.
Tell people that really do come in their pants that's locked in.
There's something locked in about them,
but it was a 100% real.
You think those people that can't or easily hypnotizable can be influenced by
that can be hypnotized by something on a TV screen maybe as possible.
Yeah mate.
Maybe why not?
I don't know what that element,
what is what's causing you to go under,
you know what I'm saying?
Like is it just the words,
the way the person saying it?
Is it them looking here?
Frank Santos was an interesting guy.
He's a very short fellow and this is coming from a short guy and he had glasses
and he was kind of like a big guy and he was heavy,
you know,
he was overweight and it just seemed real unassuming and sweet and kind and
soft.
And just,
hello everybody,
how are you?
How are you?
You know,
and you're just just talking to you.
Are you going to get sleepy?
And I get sleepy.
You get to sleep,
you're sleeping.
And they would just not off.
And he'd be like,
Whoa,
what the fuck?
He just knew how to do it and he would do it so calmly and confidently and he
would do it every week and every week we would watch,
some people would work on,
some people wouldn't work on.
I wonder if anybody can do it.
Anybody can put someone under their trans if they were taught the right way and
maybe you got to do is learn something or is it some kind of special gift or
some,
ah,
I bet it's a skill.
I bet it's a skill,
but I bet it's just like having a good personality.
Like some people,
you want to hear them talk all the time.
Dude,
what if there's dudes like that?
They go,
they date and they're just looking for girls.
Yeah,
they're just looking for girls that could happen.
The ties to live when they take them home,
make them do all sorts of crazy shit.
I knew a guy who was a comic who also worked as a hypnotist and he,
he'd hypnotize people.
And I remember walking by him while he's talking to this girl and she goes,
no,
I don't want to be hypnotized.
And I remember thinking,
well,
what are you saying her?
Oh this is back in the design to what if there was a hypnotist slash comedian
that mastered hypnotizing people from the stage?
And he got them to laugh hysterically at everything.
And so he's just like killing it.
Crushing every night.
Well I think comedy is a form of massive gnosis.
It's funny you say that,
cause I think that's what's happening when you're locked in,
like when you're locked in and everyone's locked into what you're doing and
you're killing,
there's just these moments where it's like the audience sinks minds with you.
Like hypnotism.
It's very similar because when you're killing,
there's this feeling that you get,
where are you?
Like it's an energy feeling.
It's not just you saying something and they think you're so funny.
So you feel so good.
It's like you're riding this wave and as long as you practice the material so
much that you know where the beats are and as long as you're so engaged in the
material that you really are thinking about it as you're saying it,
you're not bullshitting them.
You're not just saying the words.
Cause they know when you're just saying the words,
they want you to be fully engaged.
But there's these moments when you are fully engaged and they know you are and
you,
you're riding this wave together because you know the material so much so that
you can be fully engaged but not have to think about what comes next because you
know what comes next.
But you're saying is if you've never said it before and you're thinking of it as
if you've never thought before,
you thinking of it as if you've never said it before and they're locked in and
it's like hypnosis.
It's very,
very similar as far as I know.
I mean,
I've never hypnotized anybody,
but I feel like when you're killing,
it's a state of mind is like you're,
you're,
you're achieving a group state of mind with all these people.
It's weird.
Yeah.
That's why I say that like specials are like at the very best 80% of what it's
like to be there at the very best.
It's probably not even close.
I'm probably being super generous with what a special actually is in comparison
to being there live.
Like there's sometimes I'll see a recording and I only,
I thought that was better.
I thought that was better when I saw it live because when I was alive and I was
watching the person I was in the room,
you know,
I'm soaking up the laughs in the room.
They're all the people in the room.
Everybody took,
they took an Uber to get there.
They got drinks.
They're,
they're excited.
They're pumped up.
The guy's killing.
You're locked in.
You're in the room with these people can't believe he just had that.
Ah,
and you're all feeling it together at home.
You're getting a fraction of that.
Yeah.
You know,
it's like hypnosis,
man.
There's an energy that's being shared.
You know what I mean?
You've been doing a lot of standup now.
Don't you feel like that?
Like when it clicks,
like there's an energy that is being bounced back and forth between two people,
between you and the audience?
Yeah.
Um,
for sure.
I mean,
when it works,
you know,
I'm,
I'm a blue belt in comedy,
you know what I mean?
You're like a coral belt,
red belt,
you know what I mean?
Um,
you know,
I'm pulling it
off and uh,
it feels good even when you just pull it off and everyone's laughing at him in
the town a good time.
So yeah,
it feels those moments.
That's why I'm doing it because it's so much fun.
It's just like what I do after Jujitsu.
I mean,
I hang out with my,
my students and we just talk about the craziest shit for about 10,
15 minutes and then I go home.
That's,
it happens almost every night.
We're talking about crazy shit.
And it's the same thing.
We're making each other laugh and when it works on stage,
it's that times a thousand.
It just,
you know,
when people are laughing and everything's working,
it's great.
Obviously when it's not working and they smell blood and you're not feeling what
you're saying,
you kind of just going through the motions and that,
that happens to me.
You know,
I'm still a new in the game.
Ah,
that sucks.
That's horrible.
But luckily,
uh,
the first year,
you know,
I was just trying to figure out what the fuck was I was going to do and try to
structure my,
said I smoked,
I smoked weed before I went on stage.
I want to do that no more.
I go on and on stage,
just clear,
clear minded.
And it's way better because it's easier to remember all the material,
not stone,
you know.
Uh,
uh,
eventually I can,
you know,
uh,
go back to smoking weed like you before set because I've gotten the structure
down so well that I could just go up there and it's like,
you know,
when you,
when I teach and I do a seminar,
I got that shit down on lock.
Well,
I really liked doing sober October.
I really like not smoking before shows too.
Yeah,
it was fun.
It's fun to do.
It's different.
Have a cocktail,
you know what I mean?
I couldn't even do that sober October.
Everything was just completely sober.
I like having to drink and then,
uh,
you know,
maybe a cup of coffee,
got my blood going up.
Boom.
Like before I teach,
I have some coffee,
you know,
I'm over around.
That's one thing I do is stretch out and move around shadow box.
I get my body loose.
I just want to get the blood pump.
Then I just want to feel looser physically.
It's hard to know what when though,
you know,
like what's,
when is it?
Loser is a loser right now.
And just Kinda just,
I just,
I have just a bunch of things that I do.
I just start throwing knees,
loosen up my arms,
you know,
stretch my back out,
stretch my legs out.
You know when it works though,
man,
when you're,
um,
just like connected with the audience.
What I felt that the most so far was in Houston a almost a year ago.
And just for some reason,
man,
that crowd of [inaudible] Saturday night,
yes,
I caught away.
They were all waiting to screen.
They could,
as soon as I walked on stage,
they were already laughing.
I didn't say anything.
They were just all ready to go.
Curtis was there with Priscilla is his fiance and it was,
it was,
that was the best night so far.
I mean as far as connection and um,
man,
you know,
you're chasing that,
you always want that,
you know,
you always want that same high.
And then the next day in Austin,
man who wasn't,
it was the opposite.
We talked about this the last time you were here.
Yeah.
You got a rough set on Sunday.
Um,
you know,
had good for you.
Can I throw it a little Houston plug?
Not this weekend,
but next Friday,
June 14th.
Me and Sam triply or doing tin foil hat comedy a Friday in Plano,
Texas,
which is a just outside of Dallas.
And then Saturday,
June 15 we're back at the secret group in Houston.
That's where I,
that was my,
my favorite nights so far.
So hopefully we could do the same thing again.
I'm keeping my fingers crossed,
but man,
that I'm really looking forward to going back to Houston.
Yeah,
me too.
I'm on announcing a bunch of dates on Wednesday and Houston and Dallas are both,
uh,
on that menu.
And then we're doing another date in Colorado,
Colorado to two nights now,
23 and the 20 fourth@thebelkojoerogan.com for all the shit.
How bout those Houston gigs I used to do like back in 2004,
2005.
I remember we'd go to Houston,
man,
Austin,
those are some crazy,
those Houston was always there for some reason.
None.
Comedy town,
Dude.
They're ready to laugh.
Yeah.
Well that's with guests.
And started,
you know,
Kennison started there,
started there.
A lot of great comics came out of Houston.
It was a good spot.
So they had like a,
a real appetite from comedy.
Then,
you know,
they're,
they're smart people that are,
you know,
they're living in like a,
it's like a Texas city.
So it's like Texas,
but it's also city.
So Houston is a great spot.
Yeah,
it's one of the best.
All right,
let's wrap this bitch up,
bringing home Eddie Bravo.
Tell people,
uh,
Eddie Bravo.
Um,
you on Instagram.
It's a Eddie Bravo 10 p one,
two p.
What is it on Twitter?
Do you use Twitter anymore?
Am never on Twitter.
I mean,
it's as Eddie Bravo,
but I've never on there.
That's it.
Bye everybody.
Thank you.
That's it.
Fun Time.
How's a good one?
Man?